Hey everybody! Down, episode 152, The Future Database with Sam Lambert. Take it away, Jason. Hey, everybody. This is a super awesome episode. I'm really looking forward to this. I actually found out about PlanetScale, which we'll talk about later on from Googling on the internet, you know, how to get a self-managed database. I burn myself too many times with trying to maintain my own database. And another thing I always tell folks is the class I kind of most regret not taking is databases. As people who've listened to the show for a while,
show veterans know, I elected to take all the theory classes. I took linear algebra. I took all these things. And I didn't take networking or databases or operating systems or any of these classes that probably would have been extremely useful. And I feel like I learned most of them on the way. But the one that I really learned way too late in life was databases. So we are going to talk about, you know, kind of the next evolution of databases.
And, you know, kind of along the way, we'll dive into kind of the whole history of how people stored things. And we'll dive into a lot of that and how we can continue to make that better and more painless for engineers. So we're really excited that we have Sam Lambert on the show. He's the CEO of PlanetScale, and he's here to chat with us about the future of DBs. So thanks for coming on the show, Sam. Thank you very much for having me. Cool. So maybe just to kind of kick things off here, what is one of your greatest database horror stories? Everyone talks about the intern that deletes the prod database and stuff like that do you have any any story from your experience of uh you know crazy
database mishap you know something you couldn't even roll back or something wild that you could share with the audience out there i have so many all right let's do it this is partly why i'm doing what i've got two actually actually. I'll tell you. One inspired a product feature that we have, and we don't need to go into too much about what PlanSkill does right now, but one was in my second day at GitHub. I took GitHub offline for about an hour while making a database page, and it was the worst feeling of my life, and I honestly expected to get fired that day.
It was a very common issue that a lot of our customers face well did face until plants go and and it was real passionate for me to fix this for our users but what happened was we were around github was a rails app very large rails app with a you know a lot of users and lots going on and one of our developers had been waiting for me to join. I was the first database engineer that actually joined the company. And they had a load of schema changes that they wanted to make. And they said, you know, we've stopped using this model. You know, I want to get rid of a load of these columns and nothing's accessing these columns. So I went ahead and ran PT online schema change in those days was the kind of way to run an online database
migration. And kind of, it went through, it took and kind of it went through it took about half an hour to to do it uh and then the column dropped and the website went offline and what happened is the model hadn't been fully cleaned up and there was tables that were still you sorry there was queries that were still using that column and every single site on the every page on the site just completely broke and it was a horrible feeling. And with our audience, you know, people noticed extremely quickly because your application needs to pull from planets from GitHub to, to build or to go onto the cloud or whatever. So everyone would notice, right? Like in fact, in our load graphs, you could see the crontics of the entire
world. So on the hour we had a huge spike and you would see these spikes throughout the entire world. So on the hour, we had a huge spike. And you would see these spikes throughout the entire stack. If you look to the load balancers, if you look to the application, if you look to the database, every graph had exactly the same spike. So the hour was the biggest, half an hour, second biggest, 15 minutes, down to five, down to one. And it was people's applications, you know, they had a grant and they were just building the app whenever to deploy it or whatever, or just to build it and build an artifact.
And so that was one of those. The other, the funniest, and I can only be funny because of how crazy it was, was I was out at dinner. I was in Berlin with some GitHubbers, and I got paged websites off MySQL down. So I ran, like it wasn't far from where we were staying, so I ran back to this Airbnb, jumped on the computer, got on the box. And it said, MySQL, like clean shutdown or like shutdown initiated or whatever.
And I was like, someone has logged on and shut down our main MySQL server. And I was like, whoa, what's going on here? This is crazy. Obviously, no one had done that. There was a really weird issue. So there was another Percona tool called PTStalk. And what that did was it would say something happened in the database, like a load spike or whatever. It would try and grab as many metrics from the database as possible, like what queries were running, the NODB metrics, just so that you could debug a bit when things
went wrong. It was just a really good way of capturing a snapshot of what was going on in the system. It was also quite heavy. We used to run pretty sort of stacked database machines, really big servers. So a lot of memory and scanning buffer pools that are that size is very, very slow and was actually slowing the database server down. So earlier that day, I'd gone into Puppet to just disable PTStalk, which, you know, next time Puppet ran, it would just go to the database servers and shut down PT-Stalk. Great. So it did that on the first
Puppet run. That was fine. Then we had this incident. What happened is there was a bug in PT-Stalk that it hadn't cleaned up its PID file. And so when Puppet went to disable it it found the pid file and went to kill again to shut down pdstalk what happened is a thread of mysql had assumed that that number and mysql forwarded on the sig term to the master process and processes it as a shutdown request and just gracefully shut oh the entire database uh-huh so it was the weirdest issue i bet like it just should not have happened it was like two bugs piled on top of each other and then just a mysql shutdown and it was very like annoying at the time but then we all were able to laugh because like i mean how do you see those things coming yeah what are the chances of
that yeah exactly exactly you just got to kind of roll with it that is wild so you said you joined github and then within a couple of days you broke the site and you thought you were going to get fired this is something that that uh you know a lot of people wonder about this so i'm assuming you didn't get fired because you have a second github story but what actually happened like did you get called into the boss's office like what was the day after like everyone there were great engineers that understand that these things kind of happen like we looked at it made sure the problem couldn't happen again and went back to it okay i mean we didn't have a very blame-based culture because what's the point if you're looking for blame you're never going to find the real problems right it's only systemic problems like if you assume and this was the case in both the circumstances is you know you assume best intention and you assume that
the person does the right thing with the information presented to them so the developer was presented with the information they thought they'd moved, cleaned up the code base, and they had no other reason to believe they hadn't. So they made the next step with best intentions and with the information they have, which was to ask me to remove those columns. I probably should have checked, but at that time I didn't. I kind of just went forward with my knowledge, which was like, believe that this thing is done i'm going to go and do this and i went and did it and so when you look back at this you could if you just go for blame you miss what could actually stop this happening in the future which is like process right like that so after that yeah we wrote i wrote a checker that makes sure that no queries have happened
in that amount of time since we the model cleanup. So we knew, then we were going to cause kind of an outage if we still remove those columns. And that's how we actually improved. And throughout my career, I've always encouraged people to do that kind of postmortem. Because if you're just going for blame, you very like, I've never seen an outage where, the post-mortem someone was presented with the right information and then deliberately did the wrong thing like people just don't really do that there's a lot of interesting safety science around airplane crashes and how just giving pilots a checklist to follow in a very stressful situation improved airline safely
safety massively because it's that same insight of like, people are just going to do what they think is the best with the information they can gather at the time and gathering information in a high stress environment is very difficult. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, I kind of have a downstream story of something like that, where I was making changes to TensorFlow. this was maybe six or eight months ago i was forking tensorflow you know for a bunch of reasons and adding a whole bunch of you know kind of proprietary you know kind of operators and things in the tensorflow and um i i accidentally put in the command to push my branch to the open source TensorFlow.
And I got this message pop up and it says, hey, you know, you are not pushing to the internal TensorFlow. You're pushing to the open source TensorFlow. Are you sure you want to do this? And you could press and it was, you know, no by default, which is super smart. And so, you know, I just press no, and we moved on. And that, you know, later on, but a month after that event, someone was in our company, all hands talking about how they, you know, push something to TensorFlow and, and having a laugh about it. But you know, that, that error, you know, failure review board, or like the
contingency of that error was to implement this extra check, which, you know, saved me from doing it and a whole bunch of other people too. And so you're right, I think, instead of wasting time, like trying to blame, it's really an opportunity to fix, you know, a whole category of errors. You can understand a lot more. Yeah, totally. Very totally very cool so yeah let's uh let's dive into into you for a bit so the audience can kind of get to know uh more about you and your experience with uh with databases that kind of led to planet scale so kind of walk us through like you know what was your first time using a database you know what's kind of your kind of history with that? And at what point did you say to yourself, now's the time to go and start PlanSkill? My first kind of interaction was with databases.
I was at this company that was an e-commerce store provider. It was like more of a boutique. They did it for very fat, like fashion companies. And it was way before shopify and the likes and it was so it was a house rolled e-commerce framework and they had an incredible design team and they would produce beautiful e-commerce websites right and like really big brands would come to gain e-commerce sites and this was where or when would this be probably 2006 ish so it was a long time ago and it was php and my sequel which is still the majority of the internet and at that time was
definitely the majority of the internet but i was a sysadmin i was there to just keep websites up put websites into production we had very basic tooling for doing this because it was, you know, back then. And MySQL was the database. And so I had to administrate database service with PHP, my admin and things like that. And that was my kind of first introduction to MySQL. And after I left that company, I went to an electric vehicle company that's now not in business anymore, but they were an early electric vehicle company doing commercial electric vehicles so they were building these big electric trucks and like frito-lay and people these companies doing these local area deliveries were using these electric trucks they were very fun electric vehicles regard like regardless of their size still accelerate very
very quickly and it is very fun to floor a seven ton truck that's got a massive that's amazing electric engine so we got to do that as well that was very very enjoyable but they had this huge telemetry system and they were actually selling the data to the department of energy because they were fascinated by the usage patterns of these this very new emerging technology so we built this device that went on the box and listened to the can bus so on in every car there is a kind of a network called the can network which all of the devices in the car communicate on and kind of you know diagnostics are sent around the vehicle you know things that you know if you're getting a
warning light or whatever and we would listen to all of it and it would generate thousands of messages a second we had a sim card and we would stream this up to our data centers and we would gain all this data in real time. And we stored all that data in a massive MySQL warehouse, like just huge volumes of data coming in and having to be stored. And that is when I really got exposure to the internals of MySQL
because we were running it in such an extreme fashion. We would hit performance issues or bugs. And that's when I really got into databases and learned how fascinating they are and what a challenge they are. And that's where I kind of moved my career from just being like a general sysadmin to specializing in databases.
And it was really great fun. And I eventually made my way to GitHub where I did the same. But I've had this observation throughout my whole career the databases are too difficult they solve a really hard problem for you and then pass on a whole other ton of really hard problems for you to solve like what what are some examples well i mean look look at how difficult it is just to get a schema change into production in a normal fashion like i've got a horror story about that everyone has horror so every day you see you know someone fills out a contact us report on our website and they're
having problems with schema changes or a schema change took them down in production and it's like a really hard thing to do so when we built planet, that's one of the first problems we looked to solve, making schema changes fully online and easy enough to deploy as if you were deploying code. And people love it. And we're very productive using the platform. We get more schema changes done than I've ever seen any other company, like multiple a day. Developers just push them. The normal process in every other company, and it's a process I've set up because the database is so fragile, it has to be babysat, is you'd open a ticket, the DBAs would look at it, they'd test it, they'd run it on a staging environment, and you're waiting days. And how often do you like waiting days to get the feedback of getting something in production?
Yeah, never. Yeah, no, you just don't. It just ruins your time. GitHub had this magical culture, an incredible culture focused on shipping you had to ship something in your first day you know when you hit t on a github issue and you get that really fast uh not issue sorry on a github repo and you get a super fast search yeah yep that was someone's first day project when they joined the company they ship that by the evening. Wow. The go-to file thing, right? That was our culture was that it was all about shipping and user impact and getting the value of what we're building out there in front of people. So I had this challenge of like looking
after my SQL databases and having an internal audience that wants to ship really, really quickly. It led me to build a lot of tooling and learn a lot. And so PlanetScale, this is reflected in our product values, which is, we want to give you an extremely stable database. And the back end of our database has run some of the largest websites in the world and continues to do so. But we want you to manipulate and ship as fast as possible. And that's a really hard challenge. There's loads of like baby databases, toy databases out there that are like, we're the best for DX and whatever. It's like, but yeah, that's great.
after my SQL databases and having an internal audience that wants to ship really, really quickly. It led me to build a lot of tooling and learn a lot. And so PlanetScale, this is reflected in our product values, which is, we want to give you an extremely stable database. And the back end of our database has run some of the largest websites in the world and continues to do so. But we want you to manipulate and ship as fast as possible. And that's a really hard challenge. There's loads of like baby databases, toy databases out there that are like, we're the best for DX and whatever. It's like, but yeah, that great.
I mean, yeah, you can build against this thing super fast. There's no schema. Really good. Good for you. You can, you know, ship super quickly. And then you pay that debt down terribly. When you lose data, you ruin a customer's experience. All of those things, right? Like that trade, traditionally, it's been an either or
you want a super fast easy to use database that is just unable to do what databases do at scale or you have a database that scales and is robust with data and it's painfully hard to use and really hard to be productive with plant scale bridges that gap and that's something that really excites me yeah that makes sense yeah this is a problem that I've also seen a lot with databases. I think it's because you can't do anything atomically. Because the database is the engine for a massive data set, you can't say, well, I'm going to push this PR, and this PR is going to update the code so that my column now says foobar instead of foo, and also update the database schema to say foobar at the same time.
You can't do atomic things like that traditionally because you have a zillion bytes of data that all are expecting column foo. You also have open transactions if there's an open transaction that remembers that column not being foo do you right right club of that transaction or do you club of the ones afterwards it's a very hard problem that's one of the reasons that online schema changes are quite difficult in databases because of that issue we you know one very pop common my sql issue was that you would have a open transaction so it has a lock on the definition of the schema. Because if you change that during a transaction, you're going to mess the transaction up and transactions have to guarantee repeatable reads throughout the
transaction. So if you change the schema and you could break the running transactions, so that transaction has a lock to prevent that. But the transaction that's trying to do the schema change goes and grabs a load of other locks and waits for the lock on the table. But while it holds the other locks, it's then destroying other transactions that are trying to come in.
So you get this pileup of long running transactions that then break your website. So there's all of these really tough issues about doing this. And luckily, like we're moving forward, tech is going forward, things are getting better. And this is getting close to a solved issue. But it's not easy. And I think the hardest thing, and the thing I like the least about building a database product is you have to just push loads of trade-offs back to the user. And there's no way of being too magic,
because if you are too magic, you're going to let people down and you're going to paint, let people paint themselves into really awkward situations. And so you have to pass over a lot of choice and then you have to educate people and that's difficult and it's, it's not simple. Yep. Yep. Yeah. That makes sense. I think it'd be really good for the audience to explain kind you have to educate people and that's difficult and it's it's not simple yep yep yeah that makes sense um i think it'd be really good for the audience to explain kind of what a transaction is and uh yeah maybe do you want to take a crack at that i'm sure i'll miss something but yeah well between two of us we could fumble our way through it let's talk about the i think it would be easy to frame it and why you would want to use one and then we'll talk about why it would be achieved
i think that's the easier way of of doing it so the reason you'd want a database transaction would be in the following scenarios let's pretend you're a bank and you store your data in my sequel which a lot of banks do because of transactions and because of the durability of the database imagine i wanted to move my money from my bank account to your bank account. I have got to go and delete the data from like, like decrease the balance in my account and increase the balance in your account. And as we know,
computers crash. If a computer crashes midway through that process, after it's deleted from mine and hasn't quite put the insert into your account, the data, the money disappears and has not gone anywhere right it's just gone so yeah the delete the the kind of update has happened on my table or on my row and has not yet happened on yours and we crash
all that's happened is my balance has gone down so an ideal way is that we stage them both to happen and they don't happen unless they all happen. Unless the data gets into your account and out of mine, neither actually completes. That is why we have transactions. You do this inside a transaction. So you would begin a transaction that tells the database, I'm going to do a series of commands and I want all of them to happen or none at all. And then you would issue those commands. So you'd begin this transaction. You would then remove the balance from mine. You'd insert it into yours. And then you would
close the transaction. If all of those operations are able to complete, they all happen. If one fails, they roll back and none of them happens that is probably the simplest explanation that you then you can peel the onion a little deeper and go into why you need repeatable reason all these things but that is the simplest i can explain yeah is there ever a case where it's not possible to roll back like i'm thinking uh let's say like is there some kind of i guess to further your analogy it'd be some kind of double spending thing where, let me think about this, like to roll back, you'd have to put money back in your account. Is there something that could have changed externally to make that not happen? I guess I'm wondering, like, can transactions somehow, like still not fully protect you like can the rollback fail well if you have a you have a missing if you if you have a locking problem potentially so oh i forgot to talk about locks here we go this is why this is why it's very for a monday morning we're going
deep but we should right so yeah when when the thing the database should do for you when you remove the data from my row is lock it to say there's something going on here don't do anything else and that stops another transaction coming in and say i'm doing it again it stops me removing even more from my balance, and then making the transaction fail. So it locks that row at that same time. So when you remove the balance from me, it locks the row to say, no, there's something going on right now. No other transactions can go and add or remove balance from me. And that stops that happen. That means you can enable that rollback. If you didn't allow that to happen, if you didn't lock the row, you could have another transaction, remove all my balance, and then I don't have any balance to transfer to you.
And then we have another problem. Yeah, yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, or you could, I think maybe, like, if for some reason, people had a limit on how much money they could put in their account, then you could imagine, like, let's say you're right at that limit. Let's say the limit is $10,000. You have $10,000 in your account. Then you could imagine like, let's say you're right at that limit. Let's say the limit is $10,000. You have $10,000 in your account. You elect to pay somebody $1,000. So it debits $1,000. Now you have $9,000. Another transaction puts in $1,000. So now you're at $10,000 again. Then that first one needs to roll back and give you some money back from a failed transaction,
which would put you at $11,000, which violates some rule. So you end up in really bizarre things like that, I think. Yes. And the key point is it wouldn't be putting money back. Because of the lock. Yes, because of the lock. The removal just wouldn't happen until the insert happened as well. Yeah, that makes sense.
So yeah, what ends up happening, what I've seen a lot in code is where somebody, there's a column in a database and someone tries to sort of rename the column or put a note or something that basically says, don't use this column. Like this is our busted, you know, our old column. You know, it's an integer and we decided we really need a double here. And so we're just going to make a new column and then slowly get everyone over to the new column. And then when you finally feel like
no one's using the old column, which is also really hard because there could be things deployed using old code that aren't, you know, updating every day. So you can have old code running somewhere in your company. But if you could somehow, I guess, looking at the database logs, say, okay, no one's accessed this column in 90 days. So I'm confident enough now I can finally delete this column. And so it's like something that you wanted to just do overnight, some atomic
change is actually going to take 90 days and that's even for the most trivial thing this really tough like you even get scenarios where people's deployment infrastructure just doesn't work as well and there's always like one pod or something that's got an old version of the code that's asking it it's really really tough we we get around this by allowing you to like push these things online but it might still break something that makes sense so you know one thing that we should cover a little bit um before we come back to my sql is is all the different types of databases right there's sort of um these sort of common column column lure column lure how do you say that columnar column you're i always get i'm so bad with some
of these words like yeah i could never say that right patrick you have to give it a shot i feel like this is a word that you can get right column there yeah that might be the closest i don't know but anyways so that's that's those ones that look like you know if you've opened up excel or something you have this sort of sheet you know and you can put little titles in the first row of all the columns. That's kind of view of a table. That's the sort of canonical database. But then there's, you know, there's key value. There's these document stores like Mongo.
And I'm totally drawing a blank on some of the alternatives to Mongo. But, you know, what you're feeling about all of this, I mean, is there a new application is presented in front of you. Do you have like a process that you go through and you try and say, OK, this is the right sort of way of storing this data? Like my initial feeling on this is I used to spend a lot of time on this, and now I've just decided I can do everything in MySQL, or at least in that format. But I was wondering what your take was on that.
I mean, it's so funny you say that, because that's kind of the curve, right? Like best tool for the job. It's good to try and find the best tool for the job. However, it should really be the tool that mostly fits your use case that you can operate really, really well. Because if you're familiar and you can operate these things and kind of get it done, you're likely going to have a better experience in the long run. And there's this kind of funny progression that companies go through.
It's like, you know, maybe MySQL is good in the beginning. And then they move to Mongo. And then they always end up back at MySQL. The truth is, at massive scale, you usually end up back at MySQL. So there's loads of graph databases out there, right, that do storing graphs. Great. The largest graph database in the world is at Facebook, Tau,
and that runs on MySQL. Because they have a massive MySQL deployment, they are incredibly good at operating mysql and at the end of the day if you can build a layer on top to store graph data that is way better to the to operate than a brand new graph database is still figuring things out right like if you've got your operations down on a specific database then that's the way to do it. And even key value, we removed loads of Redis at GitHub and replaced it with MySQL because MySQL is faster
because it turns out multiple threads are quite good for performance. And so it's a really nuanced conversation. Like Mongo is great for some use cases. There's other data stores that are great for other things. It's just how you apply these things and trying to go for an over
specialized stack all the time like i speak to some people it's like we've got seven databases that we operate it's like wow you don't have seven teams of database experts you've got the one people mostly know the semi-abandoned ones that cause outages all the time and it's a real mess i mean it's a do you really want the bells and whistles features of everything it's like you don't buy a new car when you move house you either rent one or you just kind of make it work you just pile everything you can into your prius and then just go right and that's often the right way to do it you can't over specializing in your tech stack leads to horrific maintenance problems and that's why
一直使用专用的技术栈，就像我和一些人交谈时，他们说：“我们运行了七个数据库。”这听起来太疯狂了。你并没有七个数据库专家的团队，大家通常只熟悉其中半途而废的那个，而它偏偏又总是导致系统故障，这简直是一团糟。我是说，你真的需要每样东西的花哨功能吗？这就像你搬家时不会去买辆新车，你要么租一辆，要么就凑合着用，把所有能塞的东西都塞进你的普锐斯里然后直接出发，对吧？这通常才是正确的做法。过度专注于你的技术栈会导致可怕的维护问题，这就是为什么
every big tech company unifies in some way with a form of platform. And it'd be best for most companies to probably do the same. Yep, yep, totally agree. Yeah, I know that at one point, the Tao team looked at a document store and what they found was the P50 was a little bit better, which, you know, at Facebook means a lot of money, right? If you can get a little bit better, you can save, you know, millions of dollars,
每个大型科技公司都会通过某种形式的平台进行统一。对于大多数公司来说，可能最好也这样做。是的，是的，完全同意。对吧，我知道有一次，Tao团队看了一个文档存储，他们发现P50稍微好一点，你知道，在Facebook这意味着一大笔钱，对吧？如果你能做得稍微好一点，你就能省下数百万美元，
the equivalent of like one hour of Facebook's Delta on the stock exchange, you know, you could save billions of dollars, but the P99 brought down the whole thing. So basically, MySQL, at least the way that it was implemented and used there, was a little bit slower on average. Each transaction was a little bit slower. But when things went wrong, it gave you a lot more lead time and it could just handle things at the limit that we just didn't see from any other product. Yeah.
相当于Facebook在股市上一小时市值的波动，你知道，你可以省下几十亿美元，但P99却让整个系统崩溃了。所以基本上，MySQL，至少是它在那里的实现和使用方式，平均下来稍微慢了一点。每个事务都稍微慢了一点。但当事情出错时，它给你留出了更多的时间缓冲，而且它能在我们从没在其他产品中见过的极限下处理事情。是的。
Too many people evaluate the database from the point of view of querying it, which is, of course, very important. That's the thing your application is going to do a lot. But how does it fail over? How does it replicate data? How does it handle crashes? Those things really matter.
太多人从查询的角度来评估数据库，当然，这非常重要。这是你的应用程序会经常做的事情。但它是如何进行故障转移的？它是如何复制数据的？它是如何处理崩溃的？这些事情才真正重要。
Because when you drop a customer's data the customer very quickly stops caring how easy to use the database was for your developers in fact they don't give a damn they just want a reliable service that is up so with our back end has experienced failovers hundreds of thousands of times at other companies that are not us and was built at massive companies with scale problems and extremely smart engineers that's what you want to leverage i promise you if you're listening to this and you think no i still want the really fancy features i can handle the rest ask yourself that at two in the morning when you have when you cannot recover your your only top customers data or whatever you all the regrets come back and too many people are bitten by this in the in the database world it just businesses have gone bust very successful companies have gone bust because they did not have an ability to recover their data and i have never seen my sql
因为当你丢失了客户的数据时，客户很快就不在乎你的开发人员用这个数据库有多么好用了，事实上，他们才不管这些，他们只想要一个正常运行的可靠服务。所以我们的后端曾在其他公司（不是我们公司）经历过数十万次的故障转移，并且是在具有规模难题和极其聪明的工程师的大型公司中构建的，这才是你想要利用的。我向你保证，如果你正在听这个，并且觉得：“不，我还是想要非常炫酷的功能，我能应付剩下的部分，”请在凌晨两点，当你无法恢复你的顶级客户的数据或者无论什么数据时问问自己，所有的懊悔都会涌上心头。在数据库领域，有太多人为此吃过苦头了，有些企业已经破产了，非常成功的公司破产就是因为它们没有恢复数据的能力，而我从来没见过MySQL
lose data in a crash ever unless the operating system is lying to it yeah and and that's uh you know also the developer experience and and sort of the ubiquity of of of my sql and postgres these other other tools is is unprecedented I had this really dumb idea where actually, okay, it wasn't dumb, it was it was, I wanted to, to push myself. And so I thought, I'll use a graph database for something that was not a really heavy hitter in terms of performance, but this would be opportunity for me to learn about graph databases. And it's kind of like, it was kind of like using, you know, OS nine, you know, or like you get error code negative 13. And you have to go look up what that is. And it's like, oh, you know, they're the this, you know, C++ isn't supported, because they just targeted, you know, Python and, and, and JavaScript. So, so now I have to use the rest API
在崩溃时丢失过数据，一次也没有，除非操作系统在对它撒谎。是的，而且这也是……你知道的，开发人员的体验，以及MySQL和Postgres等其他工具的普遍性，是前所未有的。我曾经有过一个非常愚蠢的想法，实际上，好吧，它不蠢，它是我想挑战一下自己。所以我想，我会为某个在性能上不是真正的大玩家的东西使用一个图数据库，但这对我来说是一个了解图数据库的机会。这感觉有点像，你知道的，在使用OS 9，或者你会得到错误代码负13，然后你必须去查那是什么意思。这就像是，哦，你知道，C++不受支持，因为它们只针对Python和JavaScript进行了开发。所以，现在我必须使用REST API，
and I'm trying to make rest calls and C plus plus. And finally, I was like, this is even as, you know, a learning opportunity, this is just not productive. So it's like, okay, I did the same thing in my SQL in like two hours. And I'm not saying there's no room for innovation. I'm not saying people should not be disregarding all of those things to try new things and try and use ways to store and and query data but it's a long evolution the postgres json columns is a really good one really good story like so this was when postgres was a lot less operable. It was, you know, the origins of Postgres, it's an academic project, basically.
而且我正试图在C++中发起REST调用。最后我想说，即使作为一个学习机会，这也根本没有生产力。所以我想，好吧，我在MySQL中花了两小时就做了同样的事情。我并不是说没有创新的空间，我不是说人们不应该抛开所有这些去尝试新事物，去尝试使用存储和查询数据的新方法，但这漫长的演进过程，Postgres的JSON列就是一个非常好的例子，一个非常好的故事。这是在Postgres还远没有那么好操作的时候。你知道，Postgres的起源本质上是一个学术项目。
Oh, I didn't know that. Yeah, like, I don't know it fully, but I think that's what it came out of. I think it was, please, I'm sorry if you're listening to this and this is incredibly wrong and you're driving your car and getting really mad. I believe it came from an academic project which was more focused on teaching people SQL and was very was very good at like an implementation of pure sql and took a very long time for postgres
哦，我不知道。是的，就像，我不是很清楚，但我想它就是这么来的。我想是……拜托，如果你正在听这个，而这错得离谱，以至于你在开车时气得不行，我很抱歉。我相信它源于一个学术项目，该项目更专注于教人们SQL，并且非常擅长纯SQL的实现，但Postgres花了很长时间
to gain some of the operational uh the necessary operational primitives like replication and you know it's still not great and so they they ship json columns which is like brilliant very useful the developer community went crazy for it immediately and they were like my sql doesn't They shipped JSON columns, which is like brilliant, very useful. The developer community went crazy for it immediately. And they were like, MySQL doesn't have this. MySQL sucks. And so the Facebook team, again, Facebook, looked at that and thought, I like that idea. We would like JSON columns too. So they started working on it and they shipped it at the scale of Facebook.
才获得一些运营上的……必要的运营原语，比如复制（replication），而且你知道，它现在仍然不算太好。所以他们推出了JSON列，这简直太棒了，非常实用，开发社区立刻为之疯狂，他们说MySQL没有这个。他们推出了JSON列，这简直太棒了，非常实用。开发社区立刻为之疯狂，他们说MySQL没有这个。MySQL太逊了。所以Facebook团队，再次强调是Facebook，看了看那个，觉得我喜欢这个想法。我们也想要JSON列。所以他们开始着手开发，并以Facebook的规模将其发布上线。
So what, 3 billion daily active users or whatever? And it worked great. When they shipped in Postgres, it was really not production ready. People had horrendous problems. And the wisdom was don't use this in production. Two years later, they were both production ready. One had been delined by Facebook and run at Postgres scale. The other had let users down for two years and finally got good. So the timeline was exactly the same, right? But it was the order in which these were shipped and tested and the robustness of the implementation was what was really different about the two databases. And that
那么，大概有30亿日活用户或其他什么规模？而且运行效果很好。当他们在Postgres中发布时，它其实并没有做好生产准备。人们遇到了极其严重的问题。当时的共识是不要在生产环境中使用这个。两年后，它们都做好了生产准备。一个是由Facebook精简并在Postgres规模下运行的。另一个让用户失望了两年，最后才变好。所以时间线完全是一样的，对吧？但发布和测试的顺序，以及实现的健壮性，才是这两个数据库真正不同的地方，而这
talks about it philosophically. You can get all these hyper cool features are amazing, like awesome. And you know, there's famous document stores out there that were amazingly revolutionary. And then there's a million stories about how they lose the data. You can get this stuff if you want it. But you have to just be careful because the downside of this newness is not good. You don't want a new database. Databases take a minimum of a decade to mature. Yep, yep.
是从哲学层面来探讨的。你可以获得所有这些超级酷炫的功能，它们太棒了，就像令人惊叹一样。你知道，有一些著名的文档存储，它们曾经具有革命性的惊人表现。然后有成百万个关于它们如何丢失数据的悲惨故事。如果你想要这些东西，你可以得到。但你必须小心，因为这种新奇事物带来的负面影响可不好。你不会想要一个新数据库。数据库需要至少十年的时间才能成熟。是的，是的。
That makes sense. Yeah, the other document store I was thinking of was, I think, Orbit. Orbit DB. But yeah, totally right. And there are a number of really good plugins. sense yeah the other documents where i was thinking it was i think orbit orbit db but yeah totally right and there are a number of really good plugins so for example if you want to do vector search you know there's vector search plugins there's gis you know if you want to do spatial there's a postgres gis there's a spatial plugin for that you know one thing that when i was um trying to pick a database for the first time at the time what they were saying was basically postgres is is truly open source mysql like at
这说得通。是的，我当时想到的另一个文档存储是，我想是Orbit。Orbit DB。但是的，完全正确。而且有许多非常好的插件。这说得通，是的，我当时想到的另一个文档存储是Orbit，Orbit DB。但完全正确，而且有很多非常好的插件。例如，如果你想做向量搜索，你知道，有向量搜索插件，还有GIS，你知道，如果你想做空间分析，有Postgres GIS，有一个用于此的空间插件。你知道，当我第一次尝试选择数据库时，当时他们说的是，基本上Postgres是真正的开源，而MySQL像是在
some point they'll come bothering you for money or something like that i mean that might be really dated but what's the deal with with mys my sequel is it completely free to use is there some gotcha there no it's never happened people saw the purchase of well they saw oracle buying it and they thought oh my goodness this is the end for it my oracle have been good stewards they know how databases work inner db was built out had a lot of origins with oracle they're very good at databases, and they've kept it going. They're good stewards. I mean, there's commercial interest. When I was at Facebook, the whole Oracle PM team used to...
某个时候他们会来找你要钱或者诸如此类的事情。我的意思是，这可能已经非常过时了，但MySQL到底是怎么回事？它是完全免费使用的吗？有什么隐藏的陷阱吗？不，从来没有发生过。人们看到Oracle收购了它，然后他们想，哦天哪，这下它完蛋了。Oracle一直是很好的管家，他们懂数据库是如何工作的。InnoDB就是从那发展起来的，有很多渊源都和Oracle有关，他们非常擅长数据库，并且让它一直延续了下来。他们是很好的管家。我是说，这里面有商业利益。当我在Facebook时，整个Oracle的产品管理团队过去常常……
No, not at Facebook. Sorry, I was at Facebook. When I was at GitHub, they would show up and listen to their customers. They have some of, most of, the largest websites in the world as a user base, and users that are not paying them any money, but they still go there to make it better. And MySQL gets patches and input from all of these large companies running at scale, so it gets better and better. So it's a healthy, good open source project with some branding issues. Okay. That makes sense. Yeah. I mean, you're right.
不，不是在Facebook。抱歉，我以前在Facebook工作。当我在GitHub时，他们会露面并倾听客户的意见。他们拥有世界上最大的一些网站作为用户基础，而且这些用户并没有付给他们任何钱，但他们仍然去那里让它变得更好。MySQL从所有这些大规模运行的大型公司那里获得补丁和投入，所以它变得越来越好。所以这是一个健康、优秀的开源项目，只是有一些品牌形象问题。好吧。这说得通。是的。我是说，你是对的。
This was around the time, I mean, this is probably like 10 or 15 years ago and there's always this kind of drama. This was around the time when, you know, Android, we weren't sure if Android could keep using Java and all of that. But, you know, I mean, looking back on it now, I mean, yeah, everyone could use Java. Everyone could use MySQL. There's really no issue. It was a lot of, it's kind of a scare for nothing, really.
这大约是那个时候，我的意思是，这大概是10或15年前，总是会有这种戏剧性的事情。这大约是在那个时候，你知道，Android，我们不确定Android是否能继续使用Java以及所有这些。但是，你知道，我的意思是，现在回过头来看，我的意思是，是的，每个人都可以使用Java。每个人都可以使用MySQL。真的没有什么问题。这其实全都是大惊小怪，真的。
Correct. Yeah. It's great that these things are open source and that people can use them and they get contributions from folks that have got great ideas and great skills. Yeah, totally. So you were, did you go straight from GitHub to PlanetScale or was there something in between? I had a tour of duty at Facebook for a little while, which was really fun to see that level of scale. I just wanted to have incredible respect
没错。是的。这些东西是开源的，人们可以使用它们，并且能得到那些拥有好想法和高超技能的人们的贡献，这真是太棒了。是的，完全如此。所以你是……你是直接从GitHub去到PlanetScale的，还是中间经历了别的什么？我在Facebook度过了一段工作期，这真的很有趣，能看到那种规模。我只是对
for the Facebook engineering team. And I think it's the best at scale engineering team that's out there. They have so many phenomenally talented people and are also led by incredibly talented people. You have VPs that have 10,000 people in their org and they can talk to you about the intricate technical details of what their teams are working on. And it was just an incredible experience to be there and witness that. Yeah, totally. Yeah, I could totally double click on that. Okay, so from Facebook, when you're at Facebook, at some point, the spark ignited and you said, I'm going to, you know, quit my day job and start PlanetScale. What was that like?
Facebook的工程团队抱有极大的敬意。我认为这是现存规模化运作得最好的工程团队。他们有那么多杰出的天才，而且还由极其优秀的人领导着。你的副总裁手下有1,0000人，他们可以和你谈论他们团队正在从事的工作的复杂的底层技术细节。能够身处其中并亲眼见证，这真是一次令人难以置信的经历。是的，完全如此。是的，我完全可以对此深表赞同。好的，那么从Facebook离开时，当你身在Facebook时，在某个时刻，火花被点燃了，你说：“我要，你知道的，辞掉我的日常工作，创立PlanetScale。”那是一种怎样的体验？
How did you take that leap of faith? And what were those kind of moments like? So there's some nuance there, actually. I joined PlanetScale as the chief product officer. I didn't actually start the company. Oh, okay. Got it. I'll tell you the story actually of PlanetScale. So the founders left YouTube where they built Vitesse, which is our backend technology that PlanetScale is powered by. So Vitesse is a layer on top of MySQL. It's an orchestration and sharding scheme for MySQL that allows you to take MySQL to giant scale. So YouTube was growing, scaling, and building, and they needed a database that worked. Obviously, MySQL was the choice,
你是如何迈出那一步信仰之跃的？那种时刻是怎样的？实际上，这里有一些细微的差别。我加入PlanetScale时担任的是首席产品官。我实际上并没有创办这家公司。哦，好吧。明白了。其实我可以跟你讲讲PlanetScale的故事。创始人离开了YouTube，他们在那里构建了Vitesse，这是PlanetScale所依赖的后端技术。所以Vitesse是MySQL之上的一个层。它是MySQL的一个编排和分库分表方案，允许你将MySQL扩展到巨大的规模。所以YouTube当时在不断增长、扩展和构建，他们需要一个能正常工作的数据库。显然MySQL是不二之选，
and they needed some sort of layer to shard MySQL on top. So they built Vitesse. Vitesse was built on Borg, the predecessors to Kubernetes. So it was an environment of pure impermanence. You don't get your disks back. You don't get to go and recover a server. It's gone. So they had to build an incredibly resilient system for orchestrating MySQL. And that's really hard, like really hard to run state on stateless computers, like they just fail. And they achieved it. And they built this incredible technology. And we started using it at GitHub, because of course, GitHub was a MySQL shop. We started using it. And we were just so impressed, like it just does what it's supposed to do. So yeah, could you dive into that? So sharding is, is I guess, like's supposed to do so yeah could you dive into that so sharding
并且他们需要某种层来在MySQL之上进行分库分表。所以他们构建了Vitesse。Vitesse是建立在Borg之上的，也就是Kubernetes的前身。所以那是一个纯粹瞬息万变的环境。你无法收回你的磁盘。你无法去恢复一台服务器。它已经消失了。所以他们必须构建一个极其具有弹性的系统来编排MySQL。这真的很难，在无状态计算机上运行有状态的东西非常难，它们就是会故障。而他们做到了。他们构建了这项令人难以置信的技术。我们开始在GitHub上使用它，因为当然了，GitHub是一家MySQL商店。我们开始使用它，并且印象深刻，它就是能完成它应该做的事。所以，是的，你能深入讲讲吗？所以分片（sharding）是，
is is i guess like a way to do multi-node yeah like what what exactly does that mean what goes into that so horizontal scalability is really hard with databases you can vertically scale and we did that year for years at github we would basically buy the kind of best Dell server that they had from that generation and beef up these machines. Eventually that just becomes impossible. You also become very right bound. So in MySQL's kind of terminology, you have a leader and a follower. So you write to the leader and the followers all get the update. And so followers are just a great way of scaling reads. You can just put loads of them out there. The read traffic hits it, but you're writing to a single place. And that is where you start to see big bottlenecks. If you're writing a lot of data or you just store
我想这就像是一种多节点的方法，对吧？就像那到底意味着什么？这其中涉及什么？所以数据库的水平扩展真的很难。你可以进行垂直扩展，我们在GitHub上这样做过多年。我们基本上会购买他们那一代最好的Dell服务器，并增强这些机器的功能。最终这会变得不可能。你还会变得非常受限于写入。所以在MySQL的术语中，你有一个主节点（leader）和一个从节点（follower）。所以你写入主节点，所有的从节点都会得到更新。所以从节点是扩展读取负载的绝佳方式。你可以部署大量的从节点。读取流量会打到它们上面，但你是在写入一个单一的地方。这就是你开始看到巨大瓶颈的地方。如果你正在写入大量数据，或者你存储的数据
more data than can live on a single machine. And those replicas, the replicas of the primary just have to be an identical copy. They can't have a subset, usually. I mean, the Canbit, it's a lot of messing around. They just have to be a copy. So they all have to be the same type of machine. And once you have more data than fits reasonably on that machine, or more connections, or more writes, you're in trouble. Your database cluster is now oversaturated and you have real issues. How do you keep it so that if someone reads something from a follower, how does the follower know that the data is fresh? How do they know that the leader has a better version of it? So you do get some level of replication delay. There's always some. I mean,
超过了一台机器所能容纳的极限。并且这些副本，主节点的副本必须是完全相同的副本。它们通常不能只包含一部分数据。我的意思是，可以是可以，但这会带来很多麻烦。它们必须是副本。所以它们必须是同一类型的机器。一旦你的数据量超过了该机器合理容纳的范围，或者连接数过多，或者写入量太大，你就遇到麻烦了。你的数据库集群现在已经过度饱和，你遇到了真正的问题。你如何保证，如果有人从从节点读取数据，从节点怎么知道数据是最新的？它们怎么知道主节点没有更新的版本？所以你确实会得到某种程度的复制延迟。总归是有的。我的意思是，
normally it's very small, but then this is another scale problem, right? If rights pile up, the replicas don't get them in time. You, you, and you have your application reading its own rights.
通常它非常小，但这又是另一个规模难题，对吧？如果写入堆积起来，从节点就无法及时获取它们。你，你，你让你的应用程序去读取它自己的写入。
So it does a right. And then a read from the replica and it's not there. Then you get a failure or you get an inconsistency issue. So you can ask the, ask the replica how, um, how up to date it is essentially but again this is another problem another scaling problem is that like replication delay happens and it starts to get annoying and then so at github we had we built this kind of api that tells you which replicas are delayed so
所以它进行了一次写入。然后从副本中读取，结果数据不在。接着你就会遇到失败或数据不一致的问题。所以你可以问副本，问副本它本质上有……有多么最新。但这也是另一个问题，另一个规模扩展问题，那就是像复制延迟会发生，并且开始变得烦人，然后所以在GitHub上，我们构建了这种API，它告诉你哪些副本延迟了，所以
excuse me query the right one or you know it's just's very tricky. Sharding comes in when it gives you the ability to split tables or databases across multiple machines horizontally. So imagine, let's just take the example of a big table. Every app has one of these tables, notifications, statuses, timeline, whatever, right? There's always just one giant table that you just put loads of data in. You probably only need the recent data from it, but whatever. When that table gets too big for a single machine or a cluster of machines,
抱歉，去查询正确的那个，或者，你知道的，这非常棘手。分片（Sharding）的出现赋予了你将表或数据库水平拆分到多台机器上的能力。所以想象一下，让我们以一个大表为例。每个应用都有这样一个表，通知、状态、时间线，无论是什么，对吧？总会有一个巨大的表，你把大量的数据塞进去。你可能只需要里面最近的数据，但无所谓。当这个表对单台机器或机器集群来说太大的时候，
you then want to start sharding, which means you split the table data into chunks and distribute them across multiple clusters of leaders and followers. So you could have instead of one leader and five replicas, you could have five leaders with a replica each and you've distributed that workload across more servers and more leaders. So you get more write throughput, and you kind of can keep scaling horizontally. Now orchestrating that is a lot harder, right? How do you tell the query where to go? Well, you don't even tell the query, how do you route the query to the right place, aggregate them, joins, all of these things are really tough. So as the engineer, do you have to provide a sharding function?
你就会想要开始分片，这意味着你将表数据拆分成块，并将它们分发到多个由主节点和从节点组成的集群中。因此，你不再只有一个主节点和五个副本，而是可以拥有五个主节点，每个主节点带一个副本，从而将工作负载分摊到更多的服务器和更多的主节点上。这样你就获得了更高的写入吞吐量，并且你可以继续进行水平扩展。现在，编排这一切要难得多，对吧？你如何告诉查询该去哪里？好吧，你甚至不是告诉查询，你如何将查询路由到正确的地方，聚合它们，联表（joins），所有这些事情都非常棘手。所以作为工程师，你必须提供一个分片函数吗？
So not every, like as the person designing the scheme, yes, you have to explain how you need your data sharded. That can be very simple or quite complicated based on your needs. But someone has to make that decision and they make it at the beginning. You can reshard and change. You can change the sharding scheme, but you kind of pick it up front. It's not too difficult to do.
所以并不是每个……作为设计方案的人，是的，你必须解释你需要如何对数据进行分片。根据你的需求，这可以非常简单，也可以相当复杂。但必须有人做出这个决定，而且他们是在一开始就做决定的。你可以重新分片并做出改变。你可以更改分片方案，但你需要在前期就选定它。这做起来其实并没有那么难。
And then with Vitesse or PlanetScale, it's then transparent to the application. The app doesn't care. Got it. Okay, that makes sense. So the YouTube app had like one connection string. It thought it was talking to one database. It was actually talking to 70 000 servers
然后有了Vitesse或PlanetScale，这对应用程序来说就是透明的。应用程序根本不在乎。明白了。好的，这说得通。所以YouTube应用只有一个连接字符串。它以为自己在和一个数据库对话，但实际上它在和7万台服务器对话，
across 70 000 nodes across 20 data centers and the data was aggregated back for it so very powerful exceptionally powerful and it sharding comes with so many benefits we've done a benchmark that's on our blog where we do a million queries per second sustained and there's a graph and this is the really impressive part is how it's linear. If you double the amount of shards, you get double the amount of throughput. That is very hard to do as a database. I don't know of anyone else who's really achieved it. That level of predictability is incredibly difficult. And so sharding gives you these really, really nice dynamics. And it gives you isolated failure as well. If you've got 50 shards and the leader fails in one of those shards
跨越了20个数据中心中的7万个节点，数据会被重新聚合给它。所以这非常强大，异常强大。而且分片带来了如此多的好处。我们做过一个基准测试，就在我们的博客上，我们实现了持续每秒一百万次查询，并且有一个图表。这其中最令人印象深刻的部分是它的线性表现。如果你将分片的数量加倍，你得到的吞吐量就会加倍。作为数据库，要做到这一点非常难。据我所知，没有几个人真正做到了这一点。这种可预测性水平极其困难。因此，分片为你带来了这些非常非常好的动态特性。它还为你带来了孤立的故障影响。如果你有50个分片，其中一个分片的领导者崩溃了，
and has a couple of seconds failover, only one 50th of your user base experiences a blip instead of all of them all at once. So there's so many benefits of kind of breaking the problem down into these smaller chunks, it and it has a lot of you know lots of benefits yeah that makes sense i guess this comes back i'm still trying to wrap my head around the sharding function because i'm thinking if it's not done in a in a healthy way then every query is going to need to read from every shard but to your point if you
并且经历了短短几秒钟的故障转移，那么只有你五十分之一的用户会经历短暂的小故障，而不是所有人同时受到影响。所以将问题分解成这些较小的块有很多很多好处，它确实有很多……有很多好处。是的，这说得通。我想这又回到了……我还是在努力理解分片函数，因为我在想，如果它没有以一种健康的方式完成，那么每一个查询都需要从每一个分片中读取。但正如你所说，如果你
shard but if you put you could probably put certain tables in certain shards. So if you're reading from a table, then you don't need to read from every shard for any one table. But yeah, I think it seems like it really depends on how you set up that database and then looking at saying like, okay, here are my most expensive queries.
进行分片，但你可以把某些表放在特定的分片里。所以如果你是从一个表读取，那么对于任何单张表，你就不需要从每个分片中读取。但是，是的，我觉得这似乎真的取决于你如何设置该数据库，然后审视并说：“好吧，这是我开销最大的查询。”
And they're expensive because they're accessing every shard and then realizing okay the usage pattern isn't what I thought let me do this really expensive re-shard operation once yeah you do have so if you get the wrong sharding key you may have to re-shard some often we have to help users design a sharding scheme that works for their queries it's much better off if you locate data. So it's not as hard as it sounds because say it's users, you just locate the user's data together and you can shard multiple tables into the same cluster, right? So you do your joins and whatever within the cluster.
它们开销大是因为它们访问了每一个分片，然后意识到“好吧，使用模式和我原想的不一样，让我执行这个开销极大的重新分片操作一次。”是的，你确实有……如果你选错了分片键，你可能不得不重新分片。通常我们必须帮助用户设计适合他们查询的分片方案。如果你把数据定位在同一地方，效果会好得多。所以它并没有听起来那么难，因为假设是用户，你只需把用户的数据放在一起，你就可以将多张表分片到同一个集群中，对吧？所以你可以在集群内部进行联表和诸如此类的操作。
If you design it poorly, you may have to aggregate across all shards, which isn't always slow. Not always, but it can be. But then there's other ways as well of materializing. Another thing that Vitesse does extremely well is it allows you to materialize a table elsewhere. So what that means is, imagine you've got this beautiful sharding scheme, 99% of queries just amazing.
如果你设计得很差，你可能不得不跨所有分片进行聚合，这并不总是很慢。不一定总是慢，但有时会。不过除此之外，还有其他物化的方法。Vitesse做得非常出色的另一件事是，它允许你在别处物化一张表。所以这意味着，想象一下你有了这个漂亮的分片方案，99%的查询都极其出色。
They go to the local shard,'s fantastic this is one query there's one dashboard that needs to count up every like a user has done on the platform for tests can you tell the test you want to materialize where the result set of that query will be into another table and it can do that on the fly so then you issue that gnarly query against the perfect materialization for that query and it works super fast. So you can get around that. It's not as difficult as it seems. Again, the building of that, that is some really hard tech. That is some really hard engineering to get that right, but it has been done. And that is a code path that's like eight years old it's been used by billions of
它们去访问本地分片，太棒了！这里有一个查询，有一个仪表板需要统计平台上用户做过的每一件事……Vitesse可以……你可以告诉Vitesse你想要将该查询的结果集物化到另一张表中，它可以在运行中做到这一点。然后你就可以针对那个针对该查询完美物化的结果来发出那个复杂的查询，并且它运行得超级快。所以你可以绕过这个问题。它并没有看上去那么难。再次说明，构建这个东西确实是很难的技术。要做到这一点需要非常高超的工程技术，但它已经完成了。而且那是一条大约有八年历史的代码路径，被世界各地数十亿
users around the world as these large companies use for tests so there's there's other ways of getting around it yeah that makes sense well that reminds me of a product that i've been using recently which i'm i'm really uh a big fan of called dbt where you uh yeah and please correct the record on this i'm going to try my best as just a user of this to explain it but the idea is you have queries and instead of just running the query interactively you check this query into source control and it creates this destination table. And so you have two modes for dbt. You can either say, like run this query, you know, periodically or on a trigger or something like that.
用户所使用，因为这些大型公司都在使用Vitesse。所以还有其他方法可以绕过它。是的，这说得通。嗯，这让我想起了一个我最近一直在使用的产品，我真的是它的超级粉丝，叫做dbt，你……是的，请纠正我这里的记录，作为一个普通用户，我会尽我最大努力来解释它，但它的理念是，你有查询，而不是以交互方式运行查询，你将这个查询提交到源代码管理中，它会创建这张目标表。所以dbt有两种模式。你可以选择说，比如定期运行这个查询，或者在触发器触发时运行，诸如此类。
Or you run this query, let's say periodically and generate this output table. So for example, I have this expensive query. I don't want to run the query every time a user hits F5 on their keyboard. So I'm going to run it once per hour and then it's going to create this table. And then now when I go to the website and hit F5,
或者你运行这个查询，比方说定期运行并生成这张输出表。例如，我有一个开销很大的查询。我不想在用户每次按下键盘上的F5时都去运行这个查询。所以我打算每小时运行一次，然后它会创建这张表。接着，现在当我访问网站并按下F5时，
it's just querying the results of that query instead of having to actually execute the query. And then they have this other mode, I guess it's like ephemeral or ghost mode or something where you query a table, the table doesn something where, you know, you query a table, the table doesn't actually exist. But when you query the table, it goes and executes that that query. And that's more of like an aliasing thing where it doesn't save you any compute, but it's just easier for you to read the query than if it was some like massive nested thing.
它只是在查询该查询的结果，而不必真正去执行这个查询。然后他们还有另一种模式，我想就像是临时模式或幽灵模式（ephemeral or ghost mode）之类的，你查询一张表，这张表实际上并不存在，但当你查询这张表时，它会去执行那个查询。这更像是一种别名机制，它并没有为你节省计算资源，但比起那些庞大嵌套的结构，它让你更容易阅读查询。
And I think dbt has been really, really impressive. I'd never even heard of it until a few months ago, but I've been a big fan. Yeah, that is exceptionally cool. Now, I don't know if you tell your users this, but we're recording this a little bit ahead of time and PlanetScale has a big launch next week. And so hello from the past for anyone that we're talking to.
而且我认为dbt真的非常非常令人印象深刻。直到几个月前我甚至都没听过它，但我一直是它的超级粉丝。是的，这真的酷毙了。现在，我不知道你有没有告诉你的用户，我们录制这期节目稍微提前了一点，PlanetScale下周将有一个重大发布。所以对于我们正在与之交谈的任何人，来自过去的我向你们问好。
Yeah, that's right. If you're listening to this, this is maybe a month or two later. So we're a month behind reality. And, you know, if we keep shipping, maybe I'll be able to say hello to you from the future one day if we keep up with the base magic. But for now, we are bound by the known constraints of time and the universe. And what that means is next week, we're shipping a new product. And there's lots of people. We're showing it and demoing it to people right now.
是的，没错。如果你正在听这个，这可能是一个或两个月之后了。所以我们比现实慢了一个月。而且，如果我们继续发布新功能，也许有一天当我们的发布速度跟上时，我能从未来向你问好。但目前，我们受到时间和宇宙已知限制的约束。这意味着下周我们将发布一款新产品。有很多人。我们现在正向人们展示它并进行演示。
And they're getting very, very excited. We've been tweeting their quotes. And they're very, very, very hyped by this. And it's in the realm of what you've just described. So what we're calling it is PlanetScale Boost. And what Boost does is allows you to choose a query that is accessing your database. You go into our insights panel and you say, oh, look at this query. It takes five seconds to execute. You would press a button to boost that query. And what happens when you boost that query is that we tell Vitesse the explain plan, the execution plan of that query is that we tell Vitesse the explain plan,
他们对此感到非常非常兴奋。我们一直在发推文引用他们的原话。他们对此感到非常、非常、非常狂热。这在你刚才描述的范畴之内。所以我们称之为PlanetScale Boost。Boost的作用是允许你选择一个正在访问数据库的查询。你进入我们的洞察面板（insights panel），然后说：“哦，看这个查询。它需要五秒钟才能执行。”你可以按下一个按钮来提升（boost）该查询。而当你提升那个查询时，会发生什么呢？我们会将该查询的执行计划、解释计划告诉Vitesse，我们会将该查询的执行计划、
the execution plan of that query. And we ask Vitesse to materialize that query in memory all of the time. And we stream any updates, deletes, or inserts to the result set of that query. We stream it into memory. So you get an up-to-date real-time version of that query in memory forever. So we see people, and with the customers we've been testing it with, get thousands of percent improvements in their queries by just materializing in memory. And this replaces caching logic. This replaces invalidation logic. It replaces running Redis. It replaces all of that stack and just gives you blazing fast in memory queries with the same consistency as a database read replica. Wow, that is super cool.
解释计划告诉Vitesse。并且我们要求Vitesse始终将该查询在内存中进行物化。我们会将对该查询结果集的任何更新、删除或插入操作进行流式传输。我们将其实时流式传输到内存中。因此，你可以在内存中永远获得该查询的最新、实时版本。所以我们看到，在与我们一起测试它的客户中，仅仅通过在内存中物化，他们的查询性能就提升了数千个百分点。这取代了缓存逻辑。这取代了失效验证逻辑。它取代了运行Redis。它取代了整个技术栈，并为你带来闪电般快速的内存查询，同时具备与数据库只读副本相同的强一致性。哇，这太酷了！
Yeah, that makes a ton of sense. This reminds me a little bit of, what was that? Scuba, right? Scuba was this thing that would load into memory. And I think some Facebook folks left Facebook and started an open source version of Scuba. I don't remember the name of it, but yeah. Scuba is is amazing metrics store
是的，这非常合乎情理。这让我想起了什么？Scuba，对吧？Scuba是一个可以加载到内存中的东西。而且我想一些Facebook的人离开了Facebook并启动了Scuba的开源版本。我不记得名字了，但是是的。Scuba是一个了不起的指标存储，
for the facebook users and i think it uses similar technology but this has never been applied to a database product before like the the simplicity of just saying make this query really fast all the time and here's the amount of memory i want to allocate to do that it's mind-blowing. So we always knew it would be possible. So if you think about what's amazing about Vitesse, and you think about resharding, you just talked about resharding, right?
专为Facebook用户打造，我想它使用了类似的技术，但这以前从未被应用到数据库产品中。这种“让这个查询一直保持极快，这就是我想要为此分配的内存量”的简单性，简直令人脑洞大开。所以我们一直都知道这是可能的。因此，如果你想想Vitesse神奇的地方，以及你想到重新分片，你刚刚谈到了重新分片，对吧？
When you have lots of disparate shards with copies of the data, how you stream data consistently between those shards is extremely important. If you screw that up, you really mess your database up. And if you want to reshard, for example, you may have 256 nodes, 256 shards, sorry, there's more than a node in each shard, and you want to reshard it, you have to fan that data back in and fan it back out in a new sharding scheme.
当你拥有许多包含数据副本的独立分片时，如何在这些分片之间一致地流式传输数据是极其重要的。如果你把这个搞砸了，你的数据库就会彻底完蛋。如果你想重新分片，例如，你可能有256个节点，256个分片，抱歉，每个分片中不止一个节点，而你想要重新分片，你必须将这些数据汇聚回来，然后以新的分片方案再次分发出去。
And that's like a really hard thing to do. Machines die, you need to restart from the right place, network hiccups, all of this stuff that just makes that like quite a hard problem. That's a solved really hard thing to do. Machines die, you need to restart from the right place, network hiccups, all of this stuff that just makes that like quite a hard problem. That's a solved problem in Fertess. So that's called V replication. And we built this on top of V replication to say, you know what, you're not materializing to a table,
这真的是一件很难做到的事情。机器会死掉，你需要从正确的地方重新启动，网络会打嗝，所有这些事情都使得这成为一个相当棘手的问题。在Vitesse中，这是一个已经得到解决的难题。机器会死掉，你需要从正确的地方重新启动，网络会打嗝，所有这些事情都使得这成为一个相当棘手的问题。在Vitesse中，这是一个已经解决的问题。所以这被称为V replication。我们在V replication之上构建了这个功能，目的是为了说明，你知道的，你不是在物化到一张表，
you're not materializing to a node, you're materializing to an in-memory store and keeping that up to date. So when I first saw this when like when i first saw it actually working when the team built it i just burst out laughing because there was no other response than this is actual magic or it's just yeah so so we're ahead of time in the sense that we're a week before it launching but i cannot wait to see people's reactions when they just take that really
你不是在物化到一个节点，你是在物化到一个内存存储中并保持其最新。所以当我第一次看到这个……当我第一次看到它真正工作时，当团队构建出它的时候，我简直笑出了声，因为除了“这简直是真正的魔法”或者“这真是太……”之外，没有任何其他的反应。所以……我们是在它发布前一周录制的，但我迫不及待地想看到人们的反应，当他们拿出那个他们用作新闻动态（newsfeed）的、真的很慢的、糟糕透顶的查询时，他们曾试图重构它，但没有任何改善，或者他们把它拆成了四个查询并在内存中进行联表，结果却脆弱且充满Bug。
horrible query that they use as newsfeed, which is really slow, and they've tried to refactor it, and it doesn't get any better, or they've broken it down into four queries and joined it in memory, and it's flaky and buggy. For them just to choose that query and boost it, and then it's in memory forever, and they've solved their problems, is going to be really awesome, And I just cannot wait for people to experience it. Yeah, I mean, it reminds me a lot of things that we had to do at Facebook. There was this ML model that was very expensive.
能够让他们只选择那个查询并将其Boost，然后它就永远留在内存中了，从而解决了他们的问题，这将是一件非常棒的事情，我简直迫不及待地想让大家体验它。是的，我的意思是，这让我想起了很多我们在Facebook必须做的事情。当时有一个ML模型，开销非常大。
And what we ended up doing to make the latency was we actually executed it for every single user and then put it all into this in-memory key value store internally called Laser, which is very similar like Redis or these other ones. And that sounds kind of crazy, right? Because every day we're running this model a zillion times and the vast majority of those people won't even be on the site tomorrow. So it's just wasted. But it did guarantee the SLA that we needed to guarantee. So that's what we did.
为了达成延迟目标，我们最终采取的做法是，我们实际上为每一个用户都执行了一遍它，然后把结果全部放入这个名为Laser的内部内存键值存储中，这非常类似于Redis或其他类似的工具。这听起来有点疯狂，对吧？因为我们每天都在运行这个模型无数次，而且绝大多数人明天甚至都不会再访问这个网站了。所以这纯粹是浪费。但它确实保证了我们需要保证的SLA（服务等级协议）。所以我们就是这么做的。
It's probably still in production. Yeah. And so what you're describing basically automates that. I mean, we had to write a bunch of PRs to do that. You know, it's like if we could have just clicked a button, that'd be awesome. Yeah, right. do that you know like if we could have just clicked a button that'd be awesome yeah right and and that that is why it's so like there's companies that have achieved that level of like caching or speed but they have they put like a 20 person team of MIT grads on it to get it done not everyone has that yeah what's the connection here so I kind of interrupted you with questions
它可能现在还在生产环境中运行。是的。所以你所描述的基本上就是将那个过程自动化了。我的意思是，我们当时不得不编写一堆PR来做到这一点。你知道的，就好像如果我们当时能直接点个按钮，那就太棒了。是的，没错。去做到这一点，你知道的，就好像如果我们当时能直接点个按钮，那就太棒了。是的，没错。而且这就是为什么它如此……有些公司已经达到了那种级别的缓存或速度，但他们为此投入了一个由20名麻省理工学院毕业生成员组成的团队来完成它，并不是每个人都有这种条件的。是的，这里的联系是什么？所以我有点用问题打断了你，
but you're talking about some folks at YouTube started the test, which was either maybe a company or a product at some point that became planet scale, I guess. And then that, and then you joined. So yeah. Yeah. So it was that, it was that YouTube, they had the same realization. This is incredible technology. Like they saw that Facebook had built their own MySQL sharding. They saw that Yahoo had built their own MySQL sharding. They saw that Etsy had built their own, like everyone had sharding they saw that edsy had built their own like everyone had done this it's just like an inevitability if your company is growing massively you should just sit there and internalize the fact you'll be running on my sharded mysql one day because yeah it just happens it comes for all of us like you you can stop lying to yourself that
但你正在谈论YouTube的一些员工启动了Vitesse，它在某种程度上曾是一家公司或一个产品，后来成为了PlanetScale，我想是的。然后那个……然后你加入了。所以，是的。是的。所以情况是这样的，YouTube，他们有同样的领悟。这是不可思议的技术。他们看到Facebook建立了自己的MySQL分片。他们看到Yahoo建立了自己的MySQL分片。他们看到Etsy建立了自己的，每个人都建立了分片，他们看到Etsy建立了自己的，就像每个人都做过这个一样。这就像是一种必然，如果你的公司正在大规模增长，你就应该坐下来，内化这样一个事实：终有一天你将运行在分片的MySQL上，因为
you'll get postgres to run to that scale no one's ever ever done it. Right? Like, one day, maybe, but you can't, like, we're talking at a different scale, we're talking about hundreds of 1000s of servers, as some of these companies run, like, you know, there's public cloud level, like there's clusters at these large companies that are public cloud size, and they have one use at that company. Right? MySQL is there doing that. And at a lot of places you can't fake it just because people like gis or whatever right like i know that's a dig but like when people say when i ask people why do you here's a rant but why do you like postgres oh it's like extensions it's like none of that is going to work and i know you might not have scale so fine i'm wrong you're
是的，它就是会发生。它会降临到我们所有人头上，你可以停止欺骗自己，认为
right okay it works for you today but if you have like if you want to like succeed and you're building massively i had a founder come and talk to me last week and they were like you know we're scaling like really really quickly do you have any advice for us and one of the things i said was internalize the fact you're going to run on some sharded database and it's probably going to be my sequel right and they were like yeah yeah, that's what everyone's already told us. And that's kind of how it is. So anyway, they knew this and they built a really awesome solution for this. On a
你能让Postgres扩展到那种规模，从来没有人做到过。对吧？就像，总有一天也许可以，但你不能，呃……我们谈论的是不同的规模，我们谈论的是成百上千台服务器，就像这些公司运行的那样，你知道的，有公共云级别的，这些大公司里有一些集群，它们有公共云那么大，而且它们在该公司里只有一个用途。对吧？MySQL就在那里做这件事。而且在很多地方，你无法假装，仅仅因为人们喜欢GIS或其他什么东西，对吧？我知道这有点像是在挖苦，但当人们说……当我问人们为什么喜欢Postgres时，“哦，是因为扩展。”就像，那些东西全都不会起作用，我知道你可能没有那种规模，所以好吧，我错了，你是
containerized system, Kubernetes then gets open sourced. If you look back at the history of the test, and Google has documentation on this, and it's also intertwined with the history of Go, the test is one of the oldest Go applications. Certainly one of the largest. It was certainly like one of the largest. It was built on version 0.1.
对的，好吧，它今天对你管用。但如果你想获得成功并且正在进行大规模构建，上周有一位创始人来找我谈话，他们说：“你知道的，我们正在非常非常快地扩展，你对我们有什么建议吗？”我说的其中一件事就是：内化这样一个事实：你将运行在一个分片数据库上，而且它很可能是MySQL，对吧？他们说：“对，对，每个人都已经告诉过我们了。”事实就是这样。不管怎样，他们知道这一点，并为此构建了一个非常棒的解决方案。在一个
So our CTO gets credit in the Go docs for giving some of the most awesome feedback on Go because he was crazy enough in a wonderful way to say, why not build a massive sharding system to run YouTube and choose a language that like is completely brand new? Well, he went and did it. And then... uh rob pike's eternally grateful i'm sure i mean like i they genuinely were right they they they built so they built this amazing thing they then donated it to the cncf and then they started planet scale as a company to kind of commercialize it i and my team at github had then experienced Vitesse and so had Slack, so had Roblox, so had all these companies just started using it. Suddenly this tier of hyperscale
所以我们的 CTO 在 Go 文档中因提供了关于 Go 的最棒的反馈而受到赞誉，因为他以一种奇妙而又疯狂的方式提出：为什么不构建一个大规模的分片系统来运行 YouTube，并选择一种全新的语言呢？嗯，他去做了。然后……呃，罗布·派克（Rob Pike）肯定永远感激不尽，我是说，真的，他们确实做到了。他们构建了这个了不起的东西，然后将其捐赠给 CNCF，接着他们创立了 PlanetScale 公司来进行商业化。我和我在 GitHub 的团队当时体验过 Vitesse，Slack、Roblox 以及所有这些公司也都在开始使用它。突然之间，这种超大规模的
companies were like, this is good. We should all try and use the same technology and contribute to it. And so it got even better and even mature, more mature, very, very quickly. And we know, and there's one website that's out there that's doing 32 million queries a second, serving billions of users using this technology. And when you can harness the downstream effects of that and say, oh yeah, they have taken this to an extreme scale and all of the kinks have been worked out, it's just so powerful. So we started using it at github we all loved it and i contacted the founders and said this is amazing i would like to invest in your company and they came to the github office and they had this clarity of what they wanted to
公司觉得，这东西不错。我们都应该尝试使用相同的技术并为此做出贡献。因此，它以非常非常快的速度变得更好、更成熟。而且我们知道，有一个网站每秒处理 3200 万次查询，使用这项技术为数十亿用户提供服务。当你能利用这种下游效应，说“哦，是的，他们已经把这一点推向了极致，所有的毛病都得到了解决”，这真的是太强大了。所以我们开始在 GitHub 上使用它，我们所有人都很喜欢它，我联系了创始人，说这太棒了，我想投资你们公司。他们来到 GitHub 办公室，对他们想做的事情有着无比清晰的认识
do and they and they had the product so they started building it and kind of getting into people's hands and now this is where Vitesse isn't as optimized. If you want to put a seven or eight person team and train them up on Vitesse and get them to run it in production, it will be absolutely fantastic for you. And if you are Slack, if you are JD.com or whoever, like that's really good and really beneficial.
他们拥有这个产品，所以他们开始构建它，并逐渐将其推向用户手中。现在，这也是 Vitesse 优化不足的地方。如果你想组建一个七八人的团队，培训他们使用 Vitesse 并让他们在生产环境中运行它，这绝对会非常棒。如果你是 Slack、京东或其他什么公司，那真的是很好、很有益。
And the cost trade-off, considering that if you're at one of these hyperscale companies your database infrastructure probably costs you a couple of hundred million a year hiring up a few like hiring a couple of people to manage this really awesome open source project is a great trade-off rather than building it yourself so a lot of people do this and at github we did the same thing we thought it was awesome the database team at github was phenomenal and i trusted them so i reached out the founders i asked to invest and then i became an advisor in the company and the thing that i was seeing was that just presenting vites as is
考虑到如果你在这些超大规模公司之一，你的数据库基础设施每年可能花费数亿美元，那么雇佣几个人来管理这个非常棒的开源项目，与自己构建相比是一个巨大的权衡，所以很多人都这么做。我们在 GitHub 也做了同样的事情，我们认为这太棒了。GitHub 的数据库团队非常出色，我信任他们，所以我联系了创始人，要求投资，然后我成为了公司的顾问。我当时看到的是，仅仅把 Vites 作为
even as a cloud host was not enough to get it into people's hands and i had been at github for eight years and i'd what and i'd built user products, user-facing products, and GitHub Actions was the last thing that I worked on before I left GitHub. And I had this such passion for building products for developers because developers are amazing, creative, wonderful, and unreasonable. And if you can, in the most wonderful way, you can't bullshit them. You can't just like wave a brand on top of something, right? like this is the issue that we're seeing now is there's an explosion of database companies and they're just building great uis with like a jank back end and people are like oh this ui is amazing i'm going to use this and it's like cool that's like that's not going anywhere like you like this is like you're in
即使作为一个云托管平台，也远不足以让它真正走到人们手中。我在 GitHub 待了八年，我构建过用户产品、面向用户的产品，GitHub Actions 是我离开 GitHub 前负责的最后一件事。我对为开发者构建产品有着如此巨大的热情，因为开发者是了不起的、有创造力的、美妙的，也是不讲道理的。如果你能以最美妙的方式做到这一点，你根本无法对他们忽悠。你不能只在某个东西上面贴个品牌，对吧？就像我们现在看到的问题一样，数据库公司呈爆炸式增长，它们只是构建了漂亮的 UI 和糟糕的后端，然后人们说“哦，这个 UI 太棒了，我要用它”。这就好比，酷，但这根本长久不了，你这是在
trouble with that right um so that's a kind of an issue but i thought to myself if we can get this incredibly powerful tech that is almost an inevitability when you get to scale but actually make it the best thing to use on day one this is going to be a like a game-changing company and so i said to the founders i would love to come and join you on this mission bring me on and we'll build this product so i joined a bunch of people from github came to like the guy that like one of the earliest engineers i'm sorry not engineers designers jason who has been designing developer tools for decades came and you can this is you can see why why plant scale is so beautiful like these people that understand developers
自找麻烦，对吧？嗯，这确实是个问题。但我在想，如果我们能让这项技术变得极其强大——当你达到一定规模时，它几乎是不可避免的——但实际上让它从第一天起就成为最好用的工具，这将是一家具有变革性的公司。所以我对创始人说，我很乐意加入你们的使命，把我带上，我们来构建这个产品。于是我加入了。一堆来自 GitHub 的人也加入了，比如杰森（Jason），他作为最早的工程师之一——抱歉，不是工程师，是设计师——几十年来一直致力于为开发者设计工具。你可以看出，这就是为什么 PlanetScale 如此美丽的原因，因为这些懂开发者
and built this product that has endured in the eyes of developers for so long. Like GitHub has got 80 million developers using it and they're happy and they enjoy it. So we took that as a design inspiration with the same people and said, how do we take this incredibly powerful tech and put it into everyone's hands
并构建了在开发者眼中历久弥新的产品。就像 GitHub 拥有 8000 万用户一样，他们用得很开心，也很享受。因此，我们以同样的人员作为设计灵感，并思考：我们如何将这项极其强大的技术交到每个人手中，
so that you're not reasoning about the same things Facebook has to reason about. You're just using a database that feels like MySQL. We came up with database branching and the way that you should, we thought, why can't you just branch your database, use it for whatever environment, whether it's 10 minutes of testing, whether it's a four month long feature development product, why isn't there just an environment there that feels like production? And then when you want to change the schema, why can't you deploy it fully online like you're deploying code? We asked ourselves all these questions and took it on as a design problem and started building.
这样你就不必去考虑 Facebook 所需要考虑的那些同类问题了。你只需使用一个感觉就像 MySQL 的数据库。我们提出了数据库分支（database branching）的概念，以及你应当如何——我们当时在想，为什么你不能直接分支出一个数据库，用于任何环境，无论是 10 分钟的测试，还是长达四个月的功能开发产品，为什么那里就不能有一个感觉像是生产环境的环境呢？然后，当你想要更改 Schema 时，为什么不能像部署代码一样完全在线部署它呢？我们问了自己所有这些问题，并将其作为一个设计问题来对待，然后开始构建。
Yeah, this is actually, I wanted to ask you a little bit about the branching. So I've never seen anything like that. Actually, let me step back a little bit. So I, the way I found out about PlanetScale was I was doing a side project and I typed in, I can't remember exactly the query, so paraphrase this, but basically I looked up, you know, free hosted SQL database, something like that. And I just wanted something really lightweight. I knew I wasn't going to have a lot of usage on day one. And so PlanetScale came up and I started using it. It's really fun.
是的，实际上，我想稍微问你一下关于分支的问题。我以前从未见过类似的东西。其实，让我稍微退一步。我发现 PlanetScale 的方式是，当时我正在做一个副业项目，我输入了——我记不清具体查询是什么了，所以大概复述一下——但基本上我搜索了，你知道的，免费托管的 SQL 数据库，诸如此类。我只是想要一些非常轻量级的东西。我知道第一天不会有多少使用量。然后 PlanetScale 就出现了，我开始使用它。这真的很有趣。
Now is probably a good time to talk about there's a free tier. I'm still on the free tier at this side project, which I haven't had time to get back to. But completely free and it's still up and running. It's been really nice but uh the branching thing i never quite understood like if i make a branch of a database i start messing with the schema what happens to the data because the data shared between the branches does each branch have like start with no data like Like how exactly does that work? Every branch is isolated. It's a different Vitesse cluster.
现在可能是个好时机，聊聊这里有一个免费层。我的那个副业项目现在仍然在使用免费层，虽然我一直没时间回去处理它。但它是完全免费的，而且依然在正常运行。这真的很棒。但是呢，分支这个东西我一直没完全搞懂。如果我创建了一个数据库分支，开始乱搞 Schema，数据会怎么样呢？因为数据是在分支之间共享的吗？每个分支是像从没有数据开始的吗？……这到底是怎么运作的？每个分支都是隔离的。它是一个不同的 Vitesse 集群。
By default, it just gets the schema. If you want the data, you can have that too. And it will add data to the branch. This is a beginning of a journey, right? There's a lot more that will get a lot better about this in the future. But the idea is that you should be able to connect your application to a branch
默认情况下，它只获取 Schema。如果你想要数据，你也可以拥有。它会将数据添加到分支中。这是一段旅程的开始，对吧？未来还会有很多东西在这方面变得更好。但这个想法是，你应该能够将你的应用程序连接到一个分支，
and it's isolated. Doases are scary. When we do user experience testing, when we interview people, the word fear comes up a ridiculous amount. People are terrified of their databases. So you have to really explain to a developer. That's why it's branching, right? Because they understand, we all understand if it's a Git branch and I push to a Git branch, I'm not pushing this into production. It's separate. So we wanted branches to be a playground where you get the power of the database that you use in production. And because the more complex these systems get, the better cloud tools get,
而且它是隔离的。数据库是可怕的。当我们做用户体验测试、采访用户时，恐惧这个词出现的频率高得离谱。人们对他们的数据库感到恐惧。所以你必须真正向开发者解释。这就是为什么它是分支，对吧？因为他们懂的，我们都懂，如果是 Git 分支，我推送到 Git 分支，我不是推送到生产环境。它是独立的。所以我们希望分支是一个游乐场，让你拥有在生产环境中使用的数据库的强大功能。而且，随着这些系统变得越来越复杂，云工具变得越来越好，
the more abstract from, oh, it can run on your laptop, it is. It's unfortunate, but at the same time, it can be magical. Like at Facebook, in my second week, I pushed to Facebook.com. I can't build Facebook.com on my laptop. That would be crazy. It's millions of machines. So you get a dev server, right? That is a slice.
它与“哦，它可以在你的笔记本电脑上运行”的距离就越来越远。这很不幸，但同时它又像是有魔法一样。就像在 Facebook，我的第二周，我就推送代码到了 Facebook.com。我无法在我的笔记本电脑上构建 Facebook.com。那太疯狂了。那是数百万台机器。所以你会得到一个开发服务器，对吧？那是一个切片。
It's a powerful machine that is a slice of production. And then it takes your changes off to production through all the testing and whatever. That's awesome. That's the kind of the way we should go. If you look at Codespaces and all of these tools that allow cloud development, we're getting towards that world where everything's cloud native.
它是一台强大的机器，是生产环境的一个切片。然后它通过所有的测试及其他流程，将你的更改带到生产环境中。这太棒了。这正是我们应该走的方向。如果你看看 Codespaces 和所有这些允许云开发的工具，我们正在走向一个一切皆云原生的世界。
You can't simulate it on your laptop anymore. And so that's why we wanted branching in the cloud. And it gives you this isolated environment to play and make schema changes without breaking anything. And then when you want to get that schema change into production, you deploy it on plant scale through a deploy request, which is like a pull request that will then,
你再也无法在笔记本电脑上模拟它了。这就是为什么我们需要云端分支的原因。它为你提供了一个隔离的环境来玩转和修改 Schema，而不会破坏任何东西。然后，当你想要将 Schema 的更改投入生产时，你通过 PlanetScale 上的部署请求（deploy request）来部署它，这就像是一个拉取请求（pull request），然后，
no matter what you ran on your branch, it doesn't matter if you ran 500 different schema changes, all we do is look at the end state of the database and say, we will get that into production for you in the quickest, easiest way without any locking or blocking. So your application will experience no downtime. It will just deploy. And that is extremely powerful. So we have really large users that tell us, and we have case studies where they say, yeah, I mean, schema changes have gone down from two weeks to two hours. No one's scared of the database anymore. They just roll it into prod. And that was so important to us initially, to give people incredibly powerful technologies, and the isolation, a lack of foot guns to move extremely fast while using them. Yeah, that makes sense. So So then I guess, you know, when you make a branch,
无论你在分支上运行了什么，都无所谓，即使你运行了 500 个不同的 Schema 更改，我们要做的只是查看数据库的最终状态，并说：我们将以最快、最简单的方式为你将其投入生产，没有任何锁定或阻塞。因此，你的应用程序不会经历任何停机。它直接就部署了。这非常强大。所以我们有非常大的用户告诉我们，我们有这样的案例研究，他们说：是的，Schema 更改的时间从两周缩短到了两小时。再也没有人害怕数据库了。他们直接把它推送到生产环境。这最初对我们来说非常重要，为人们提供极其强大的技术，以及隔离性、没有枪走火（foot guns）的风险，从而在使用的同时能够极快地行动。是的，这说得通。所以我想，你知道，当你创建一个分支时，
you should also have some kind of a program that will seed seed that branch with some seed data so that when you point your dev website to the branch, it's not just empty. So you create some program that either copies some data out of master or out of the main branch or just seeds it with some synthetic data. Yeah. What we found was a lot of people already have those seed scripts. And so it's kind of easy for them to just like run them. People use actions to do this. This is all configurable on our command line.
你也应该有一些程序用一些种子数据（seed data）来填充（seed）那个分支，这样当你的开发网站指向该分支时，它就不只是空的。所以你创建了一些程序，要么从主库（master）复制一些数据，要么从主分支复制，或者只是用一些合成数据来填充它。是的。我们发现很多人已经有了这些种子脚本。所以对他们来说，运行这些脚本非常容易。人们使用 Actions 来做到这一点。这一切都可以在我们的命令行上进行配置。
You can create branches, do whatever from there. So people often have like, okay, give me an environment. It like creates a branch, it puts the data in, they test it and it goes away when it's done like that sort of stuff is all very possible or you tell us which backup you wanted to like add to a branch and it just happens again branching is a powerful primitive for many things when you restore a backup you can choose to restore over your main branch which you shouldn't really do and there's not many people that need to completely roll their database back. So instead, you add a load of backups to different branches and sift through the ones you need and just restore the data that way. So it's just a really powerful
你可以从那里创建分支、做任何事情。所以人们经常会说：好吧，给我一个环境。它创建一个分支，放入数据，他们测试，测试完后它就消失了。诸如此类的事情都是完全可能的，或者你告诉我们你想要将哪个备份添加到分支中，它就会发生。同样，分支是许多事情的强大原语。当你恢复备份时，你可以选择覆盖你的主分支——你其实不应该这样做，也没有多少人需要完全回滚他们的数据库。相反，你将大量备份添加到不同的分支中，筛选出你需要的，然后以这种方式恢复数据。所以这只是一种非常强大的方式，
way of giving people really cheap, easy environments and getting rid of staging. If you've got complex infrastructure, staging is just a second production that breaks every day and ruins the developers like daily lives yep yep yeah totally true i read a really interesting article about foreign keys like as the tests and plan scale don't support foreign keys so you can't do like cascaded deletes and stuff like that kind of like tell the audience you know i mean the article did a pretty good job but kind of walk the audience through that. Because I remember when I first learned about MySQL, I thought foreign keys were amazing. I thought, oh, I could have a credit card for a person. And when I delete the person, the credit card gets deleted.
为人们提供非常廉价、简单的环境，并摆脱测试环境（staging）。如果你有复杂的架构，测试环境不过是每天都会崩溃并毁掉开发者日常生活第二个生产环境罢了。对对对，完全正确。我读过一篇非常有趣的文章，关于外键的，就像测试版和 Plan Scale 不支持外键一样，所以你不能做级联删除之类的事情。能不能向听众介绍一下，我的意思是那篇文章做得很好，但能不能向听众大致讲讲这个。因为我记得当我第一次学习 MySQL 时，我觉得外键太棒了。我想，哦，我可以为一个人员关联一张信用卡。当我删除这个人时，信用卡也会被删除。
And so you kind of walk people through like the dangers of foreign keys and or maybe just on the technical side. What's the limit there? So we allow you to have foreign keys in the sense that you can have relationships, you can have joins, you can have all the things you need in a relation database. The thing we don't have right now, and it's something we know about, we're working on is foreign key constraints. As they are implemented right now, they are unscalable and do not work with online schema changes. So it was, you know, we want people to default in things that are going to work for them
所以你可以向大家介绍一下外键的危险，或者可能只是从技术角度讲讲。那里的限制是什么？所以我们允许你拥有外键，从你可以拥有关系、可以有连接（joins）、可以拥有关系数据库中所需的一切的意义上来说。我们现在没有的、也是我们知道的、我们正在努力的是外键约束（foreign key constraints）。按照它们目前的实现方式，它们是不可扩展的，并且无法与在线 Schema 更改一起工作。所以，你知道，我们希望人们默认使用那些能够为他们长期服务的
in the long run. And foreign key constraints at this moment are not a scalable pattern. So what does that mean, actually? Because I didn't know the difference. What's a foreign key constraint versus a foreign key? A foreign key constraint is when the database will automatically do that cascading for you. Okay, got it. If you use an ORM, the ORM can handle it. Like dependent delete in Rails does exactly what you're talking about
东西。而外键约束在目前并不是一个可扩展的模式。那实际上意味着什么呢？因为我不知道区别。外键约束与外键有什么不同？外键约束是指数据库会自动为你执行该级联操作。好的，明白了。如果你使用 ORM，ORM 可以处理它。就像 Rails 中的 dependent delete 完全实现了你所说的功能，
and isn't relying on the database to do it. Oh, I see what you're saying. Okay, okay. Now I think, let me see if I can paraphrase this. So if you have a foreign key constraint, like the one I gave is cascade delete, then you just need to issue a delete command to database and database will effectively turn it into a transaction where it'll guarantee that it'll delete all of these
并且不依赖数据库来完成。哦，我明白你的意思了。好的，好的。现在我想，让我看看我能不能复述一下。所以如果你有一个外键约束，比如我给出的级联删除，那么你只需向数据库发出一个删除命令，数据库就会有效地把它变成一个事务，保证它会删除所有这些
dependencies. But you're saying you can do the same thing just at one level up in the abstraction and say, I'm going to create a transaction that deletes JSON and deletes all of JSON's credit cards and then closes the transaction. I have basically the same constraint now, just one layer up. Correct. And a lot of people rely on this for their database to do it or to check that the relationship is there the other side, for example. This is a functionality we do not support right now. Now, there's a chance you will in the future,
依赖项。但你是说，你可以在抽象层上再高一层做同样的事情，说：我要创建一个事务，删除 JSON，删除 JSON 的所有信用卡，然后关闭事务。我现在基本上有了相同的约束，只是高了一层。没错。而且很多人依赖数据库来做这件事，或者检查另一侧的关系是否存在，例如。这是我们目前不支持的功能。现在，将来有可能支持，
but it also makes online schema changes not possible while you have those because the way online schema changes work is you create a copy of the table you migrate the data into your schema do the schema change and you migrate the data in and then swapping those tables in place breaks the constraints that are already there so you'd have to remove the constraints and we add them and it's tricky right so we don't love that you can't have it. But it's very much within our philosophy to say, let's inform users and give them things primitives to use
但这也使得在线 Schema 更改在你拥有这些约束时变得不可能，因为在线 Schema 更改的工作方式是：你创建表的副本，将数据迁移到你的 Schema 中，进行 Schema 更改并迁移数据，然后就地交换这些表会破坏已经存在的约束，所以你必须删除约束，然后我们再添加它们，这很棘手，对吧？所以我们不喜欢你不能拥有它。但我们的哲学非常符合这一点，那就是：让我们告知用户，并为他们提供原语，
that will serve them well in the long run and maybe has a little bit of an upfront kind of extra complexity or at least cost. But in the long run, you pay pay it down like it's the same with these no sql document stores they would tell developers you don't have to think about a schema thinking about schema is a waste of your time and then like you throw a load of documents in and now you just have the most horrifically like badly laid out data that is really hard to scale and use and you have to do like horrible hacky things to get around it like actually thinking about a schema up front is a good thing because it lays things out
这些原语在长期内对他们很有用，可能前期会有一点额外的复杂性，或者至少有成本。但从长远来看，你会还清它——这和那些 NoSQL 文档存储是一样的，它们会告诉开发者：你不需要考虑 Schema，考虑 Schema 是在浪费你的时间。然后你扔进去一堆文档，现在你只有一堆布局极其糟糕、极难扩展和使用的数据，你必须做一些可怕的、打补丁的事情来绕过它。实际上，前期考虑 Schema 是一件好事，因为它规划了布局，
and it means that you have structure to your data and keeps it a little bit neater and if it's easy to modify the schema then you get the upside without really any of the downsides yeah that makes sense actually Actually, this gets to another kind of question, which is, you know, my background is as a sort of developer, someone who has very limited use of knowledge of databases. And so I tended to be kind of dismissive of stored procedures. I kind of felt like stored procedures just seem like an anti pattern, seem like code that really, you know, logic that really belongs somewhere else. I was wondering what your take is on this. Like when are stored procedures useful? Like when should
这意味着你的数据具有结构，并且保持得更加整洁。如果修改 Schema 很容易，那么你就能获得好处，而几乎没有任何缺点。是的，这很有说服力。实际上，这引出了另一个问题，那就是，我的背景是一个开发人员，一个对数据库知识非常有限的人。所以我往往有点排斥存储过程。我总觉得存储过程似乎是一种反模式（anti-pattern），感觉像是真正属于其他地方的代码、逻辑。我想知道你对此有什么看法。存储过程在什么时候有用？人们在什么情况下应该使用它们，
people be using them versus just putting that logic in their application code? I have run my SQL at scale across many companies and never have seen the never have store procedures been worth it yeah okay we're on the same page okay i guess there's not a bunch of a debate there yeah every time i've seen it it's been a project that for a hundred other reasons has not been engineered correctly that just seems to be the pattern i've found yeah yeah it's just there's just some some real abuse happens to databases and it's never really a good idea and there's like some shortcuts but not many if you can you just have to try and keep it sensible the worst the customers that are in the worst pain that require the most help are the ones that for us that have gone they've got too clever with
而不是把逻辑写在应用代码里？我在许多公司大规模运行过 MySQL，从来没有见过存储过程是值得的。好吧，我们看法一致。好吧，看来这没什么好争论的。是的，我每次看到它，都是一个由于其他一百个原因而没有被正确设计出来的项目，这似乎是我发现的模式。是的，是的，数据库确实会受到一些真正的虐待，这从来都不是一个好主意。里面有一些捷径，但不多。如果可以的话，你只需努力保持理性。那些处于最痛苦中、需要最多帮助的客户，对我们来说，就是那些在他们正在做的事情上
what they're working with now and it's really really hard to get like you're only you losing at that point in the in the in the pitch deck that we made when i joined the company i had this graph that goes up and it's a graph of innovation and and kind of velocity for your company goes up like when you draw when you start a startup and there's like three of you, you're shipping code all day and you're talking to those first users and they're like, why don't you do this? And you're like, cool.
变得过于聪明的人，现在真的很难把——在我和公司签约时制作的那份推介文稿中，我有一个向上的图表，那是关于贵公司的创新和速度的图表。当你创立一家初创公司时，你们只有三个人，你整天都在交付代码，你和那些第一批用户交谈，他们说：你为什么不这样做？而你说：酷。
And you do it in two minutes and they're like, wow, you're amazing. That's awesome, right? Like look at GitHub, just rocket ship growth from the first week. They just put something out there. Chris's early tweets of just like, I'm going to set up a Git server.
你在两分钟内就做好了，他们说：哇，你太棒了，这太酷了，对吧？就像 GitHub 一样，从第一周开始就是火箭式增长。他们只是把东西推向市场。克里斯（Chris）早期的推文只是说：我要搭建一个 Git 服务器。
Oh, that was very difficult. Don't like that. I'm going to, I'm sure other people have these problems. Let me build this thing. And then everyone's like, yeah, I love it. And it goes really quick. And then on this graph, there's a plateau of the middle years of your company, which is where you have to hire tons more engineers.
哦，那太难了。我不喜欢这样。我要——我相信其他人也有这些问题。让我构建这个东西。然后每个人都说：是的，我喜欢它。进展非常快。然后在图表上，是你们公司的中期平稳期，在这个阶段你必须雇佣大量的工程师，
You have to start paying down all the bad decisions you made in the early days. And like, you're losing at this point, Your company is losing its potential maximum valuation while you solve database problems because your users do not care. We all use those products. It's like, oh my God, this is amazing. They're building stuff for all the time. They're building my dream product.
你必须开始偿还你早期做出的所有糟糕决定。在这个阶段你正在失分，当你在解决数据库问题时，你的公司正在失去其潜在的最大估值，因为你的用户根本不在乎。我们都用过那些产品。会觉得：哦，天哪，这太棒了！他们一直在构建东西。他们在构建我梦想的产品。
And then they go quiet and they stop shipping. Some part of their stack has stopped scaling. That's what's happened. And they're just spending all of their roadmap time bailing themselves out and then people are looking for other products or other ankle biter kind of startups are starting and exploiting the fact that you're now slow and old and and they're doing like that's really tough that this was the vision for planet scale was that you don't have that middle year plateau where you inevitably replace that Heroku Postgres database that was super easy to set up and get going on
然后他们安静下来，停止了交付。他们的技术栈的某一部分停止扩展了。这就是发生的事情。他们把所有的路线图时间都花在自救上，然后人们开始寻找其他产品，或者其他像寄生虫一样的初创公司开始涌现，利用你现在变得迟钝和老旧的特点进行攻击，而他们在做——这真的很难。这就是 PlanetScale 的愿景：让你不必经历那种中期平稳期，在那里你不可避免地要替换那个在第一天非常容易设置和运行的 Heroku Postgres 数据库，
day one and now just fundamentally just doesn't work anymore. Yeah, I think there's a lot of parallels between this and our interview with Guillermo Rauch from from next js where um and i was telling him the the story that i'll rehash now where when i start and again i'm also not a front-end guy either so when i started with next js it just kept giving me errors like it just wouldn't let me do things and i was like what the heck you know this is so annoying um but then once i once i found how to do what I wanted to do in that pattern, it took like half of my website and that and a hundred other things that you know would be things that i would eventually have to tackle if this got that that popular right and they were just done right and so i think that's one of those cases where um you know when you use an opinionated framework it'll keep you from making a lot of these mistakes the stored procedure thing i was
而现在它根本无法工作了。是的，我认为这与我们对来自 Next.js 的吉列尔莫·劳奇（Guillermo Rauch）的采访有很多相似之处。当时我告诉他一个故事，我现在再复述一遍：当我开始时——同样，我也不是前端出身——当我开始使用 Next.js 时，它一直给我报错，就是不让我做我想做的事，当时我想：搞什么鬼，这太烦人了。但后来，一旦我找到了如何在那个模式下实现我想要的功能，它就帮我解决了网站的一半问题，以及其他上百个如果这个网站变得如此受欢迎，我最终必然要应对的问题，而这些问题当时就已经直接搞定了。所以我想，这就是那种情况，
thinking of this was a really long time ago. I mean, this was in the 90s, but basically we didn't have, I was basically the first application developer. We had a database administrator and then we had a couple of people who also didn't really know what they were doing on the app dev side.
你知道，当你使用一个有主见的（opinionated）框架时，它会阻止你犯很多这样的错误。关于存储过程这件事，我想到的已经是很久以前的事了。我的意思是，那是在 90 年代，但基本上我们没有——我基本上是第一个应用开发人员。我们有一个数据库管理员（DBA），然后还有几个人在应用开发端也不是很清楚他们在做什么。
And so, you know, because the DBA was strong, you know, he did a lot of the logic and stored procedures to limit the complexity on the app side but then you it just didn't really work and so then now you have to play catch up so it's like okay now i have to instead of starting from you know a foundation now i have to start from from nothing because we had been walking on the crutches of stored procedures so yeah it's really hard to refactor and get out of how big was that engineering team that was maybe five or six people it was pretty small and one of them was a dedicated dba yeah exactly yeah crazy all dbas are there to do mainly is to mitigate downside right like dbas are there to stop outages it's a very hard job by the way like saints that do this work it's extremely hard
所以，因为 DBA 很强势，他把很多逻辑写在了存储过程里，以限制应用端的复杂性。但后来它真的行不通，所以你现在必须去补救。这就好比，好吧，现在我不是从一个基础开始，而是必须从零开始，因为我们一直在靠存储过程这副拐杖走路。所以，是的，重构并摆脱这种状态真的很难。那个工程团队有多大？可能五六个人吧。非常小，其中一个人还是专职的 DBA。
having like a fifth of your engineering team be assigned to just so something doesn't break it's insane to me that this is why we do what we do because it just shouldn't be that way. Like it's wild. The databases are so unapproachable, but essential that you have to spend a fifth of your engineering team on just stopping it going wrong. Like the value to a product of the database working well is very clear but no one there's not many like features that are solely enabled by the the database in in a sense that like you need them to build the features but it's not like this is a really rad feature that we're exposing to you
对，完全如此。疯狂。所有 DBA 的主要工作其实就是降低下行风险，对吧？比如 DBA 的存在是为了阻止故障发生。顺便说一句，这是一份非常艰难的工作，干这行的都是圣人，极其艰难。让你的五分之一的工程团队去专门负责防止某些东西崩溃，这在我看来太疯狂了。这就是我们为什么要这样做，因为它本不该是这样的。太荒谬了。数据库是如此难以接近，但又是如此必不可少，以至于你不得不把五分之一的工程团队花在防止它出错上。数据库运行良好对产品的价值非常明确，但没有什么——没有多少功能是完全由数据库启用的，
because it's a feature of the database like that's not true you abstract over the database every time so they'd have something dedicated just to make sure it doesn't do the really bad thing that they predictably always do. It's wild. It's just an insane sink on innovation. And it's still, we're not there yet where I think people are still okay with this or they're not okay with this.
从某种意义上说，你需要它们来构建功能，但它并不是那种“这是一个我们向你展示的超级酷的功能，因为它是数据库的一个功能”——事实并非如此。你每次都在数据库之上进行抽象。所以他们会安排专人确保它不会做那些他们可预见地总是会做的非常糟糕的事情。这太疯狂了。这简直是创新的一大黑洞。而且依然，我们还没有达到那种地步，我认为人们仍然对此感到可以接受，或者他们对此感到无法接受。
And they don't understand that there's a better world. They are, you know, you talk to companies that they, they do not realize how deep in the mud they are because they're their database choice yep yep imagine if you had uh i'm the i'm the electrical administrator and when the electricity doesn't flow the right way you call me up like we would just never get anything done you know i stare at the green light and if it goes red i do something oh man really really cool so let's talk about plant scale as a company for for a moment so
而且他们不明白其实有一个更好的世界。你会和一些公司交谈，他们根本没有意识到自己陷得有多深，因为他们的数据库选择……对，对，想象一下，如果我是——我是个电气管理员，当电流没有按正确方向流动时，你就打电话给我——那我们真是什么都干不成了。你知道，我盯着绿灯看，如果它变红了，我就做点什么。哦天哪，真的非常酷。所以让我们暂时谈谈 PlanetScale 这家公司，
you know what is roughly the size of plant scale and and where is it located is there like a headquarters is it kind of like uh you know one of these companies telling everyone to come back in the office is on the other side where where it's completely you know like globally uh distributed so what is plant scale like plant scales around 80 people and we're based on the internet all right with it's an extremely remote culture. We don't have an office. We're distributed around the globe. Partly that was because, you know, a lot of people came from GitHub,
你知道，PlanetScale 的规模大致是怎样的？它位于哪里？有什么总部吗？它是不是那种要求每个人都回到办公室的公司？还是在另一个极端，它是完全……你知道的，比如全球分布式远程办公？PlanetScale 的情况是怎样的？PlanetScale 大约有 80 人，我们立足于互联网，好吧。这是一个极其远程的文化。我们没有办公室。我们在全球各地分布式办公。部分原因是因为，你知道，很多人来自 GitHub，
which GitHub was that way and was probably an early pioneer of that culture. It's just the best place to do work, really. A home, isn't it? I think now. Yeah, it's the most available conference room. That's for sure. Exactly. You're right. I love that. I've never heard that before. That's fantastic. You know, I loved going to the GitHub office. It's an amazing office, kind of legendary in terms of how beautiful and wonderful and they put loads of time into it. Didn't seem like a,
GitHub 就是那种运作方式，并且可能是这种文化的早期开拓者。说实话，这真的是工作最好的地方。一个家，不是吗？我现在这么觉得。是的，这是最容易订到的会议室，那是肯定的。完全正确。我太喜欢了。我以前从未听过这种说法。这太棒了。你知道的，我喜欢去 GitHub 办公室。那是一个了不起的办公室，在如何设计得美丽、奇妙以及投入大量时间方面可以说是传奇。它看起来不像是一个——
no office has ever felt like a place to me where you just sit down and really get the work done right like facebook was an in-office culture and it worked well but they had to push it if that makes sense it was like yeah it was in a way that it was impossible to be effective if you weren't in the office right or one of the offices because your team was located around you and look i love everyone that works at plan scale if i could click my fingers and get us all into one really expensive building in soma i'd probably do that right like if i could because it would be really cool to see everyone every day and it would be really great for bonding it's just not an option i have right the person who's built like the team that are building Booster are over in Europe right now.
对我来说，没有任何办公室会觉得是一个你能坐下来真正把工作完成的地方，对吧？就像 Facebook 是一种办公室文化，它运行得很好，但他们不得不去推行它，如果这么说能懂的话。这就好像，如果你不在办公室，就不可能高效率地工作，对吧？或者不在其中一个办公室，因为你的团队就在你周围。听着，我喜欢所有在 PlanetScale 工作的人。如果我打个响指就能把我们所有人召集到索玛（SOMA）一栋非常昂贵的建筑里，我可能会那么做，对吧？如果可以的话，因为每天能见到每个人会很酷，这对团队凝聚力也非常棒。但这根本不是我能有的选择，对吧？构建 Booster 团队的人现在正在欧洲。
One's in Spain. One's in the Netherlands. A few over in New York. Like I want the best people. We've hired like some of the best engineers that work to GitHub. They're not moving. They don't want to. They have their life.
一个在西班牙。一个在荷兰。几个在纽约。我想要最优秀的人。我们雇用了曾在 GitHub 工作的一些最优秀的工程师。他们不会搬家。他们也不想搬。他们有他们的生活。
So I just don't have a choice, right? So we work with how we work with it. We manage. It's nice to be asynchronous it's great to like you know i work long and strange hours and i would feel really stuck if i had to be in an office to have any effect for of the work i do so i love it you can get a lot done in slack yeah it has downsides you can't just tap someone on the shoulder and whiteboard something out which is something that's very very powerful so you have to make up for that. I'm not one of those remote
所以我根本没得选，对吧？所以我们顺应现状进行工作。我们设法克服。异步工作感觉很好，太棒了，你知道的，我工作时间长而且奇怪，如果我必须呆在办公室才能对我做的工作产生任何影响，我会觉得自己被困住了，所以我很喜欢这样。你可以在 Slack 里完成很多工作。是的，它也有缺点，你不能只是拍拍某个人的肩膀，然后在白板上勾勒出点什么，而这是一种非常非常强大的能力。所以你必须弥补这一点。我不是那种
people that pretend the remote is like the solve for everyone and that everyone should be remote. Like, I just don't believe that. I think it has incredible upsides, some quite severe downsides. And so is the in-office culture as well. Yeah, really well put. Yeah, I remember one time where I walked into Facebook in the morning. I took the bus, which sounds like maybe you lived in the city. I don't know if you worked in the city office, but I had this huge bus commute that took forever. I lived more rural and got in the office. And just, you know, there's certain days like this where you feel really in the zone. And, uh, I remember, um, just being there the whole day and, you know, running a different people and, and, uh, you know, being able to eat all your meals there. So you can
假装远程办公是解决所有问题的方案、且所有人都应该远程办公的远程主义者。不，我只是不相信这一点。我认为它有令人难以置信的好处，也有一些相当严重的缺点。办公室文化也是如此。是的，说得太好了。是的，我记得有一次我早上走进 Facebook。我坐了巴士，听起来你可能住在城里。我不知道你是否在市中心的办公室工作，但我有巨长的巴士通勤时间，花了很长时间。我住得比较偏远，来到办公室。然后，你知道，总有那么几天，你会觉得自己完全进入了状态。而且，我记得，
really focus. And then, um, you know, worked like crazy hours, got some product out and then, you know, spent like two or three days at home where I was like, just kind of recovering from, from that kind of like crazy blitz. And so I can't like, likewise, I can't really say, you know, there's pros and cons to everything. I can't really find anything specific about working remote or working in the office. I mean, clearly like having the accessible food is really nice. Not being able to get a conference room is really annoying. But there's just not really any way to fix either of those things. So it's like it's just going to be two different environments.
就在那里呆了一整天，你知道的，遇到不同的人，能够在那儿吃所有的饭菜。所以你可以真正集中注意力。然后，你知道的，疯狂工作了很长时间，搞定了一些产品，然后，你知道的，在家呆了两三天，就像是从那种疯狂的冲刺中恢复过来。所以我也不能——同样地，每件事都有利有弊。我无法真正指出关于远程办公或办公室办公的具体哪一方面。我的意思是，显然有触手可及的美食真的很不错。无法找到会议室真的很烦人。但根本没有什么方法可以解决这两者中的任何一个。所以这就好像它只是两个不同的环境。
And we're just going to make the best of both of them. You can build some great energy in an office culture, right? Like you can feel excitement when there's things to be excited about. Like you just kind of we are incredibly social creatures we pick up on social cues that you don't you're not even aware of right like presenting on a zoom i'm telling you a zoom all hands with 80 people looking at you it feels not so great but when i presented in personal hands at github you can hear people's like you see their nods of approval you can hear their kind of like subtle gestures of approval or like the like when people clap or they get excited or you just feel the energy it's way more energy in person yeah yeah i'm not gonna just like
我们要做的就是充分利用这两种环境。你可以在办公室文化中建立一种巨大的活力，对吧？就像当有值得兴奋的事情时，你能感受到那种兴奋。就像我们本来就是极具社交性的生物，我们会捕捉到那些你甚至没有意识到的社交线索，对吧？在 Zoom 上做展示——我告诉你，面对 80 个看着你的 Zoom 全体会议，感觉并没有那么好。但当我在 GitHub 亲自做全体会议展示时，你可以听到人们的声音，比如你可以看到他们赞许的点头，你可以听到他们那种微妙的赞许手势，或者像人们鼓掌、兴奋时的反应，或者你只是能感受到那种能量。面对面的能量要大得多。是的，是的，我不会去
pretend that's not real right it's not the same at the same time what you have to do to get that is not always what companies are willing to do. And yeah, like it was awesome at Facebook, right? Like, you know, you'd walk past, say, like the two of the best network engineers in the world arguing on a whiteboard and you listen, you get like, that doesn't happen in a remote company you may hop on a zoom and get it done but it's still not the same it's it's it's different and junior folks early career folks struggle a bit more in a remote environment like when you've gotten people that are new and they're learning the craft you can see when they're getting stuck they kind of sit near their manager and they're looking a bit disengaged or a bit worried and you know they seem stressed like it's easier to check in on people yeah i've seen in remote cultures early career folks getting really stuck and they feel the barrier of scheduling a zoom call is a bit more too more it's too much formality compared to just saying oh can we just walk to the kitchen for a quick coffee and i just got a couple of questions for you like that's such yep lower barrier than than jumping on a zoom so it's again it's just all ups and downs
假装这不是真的，对吧？它是不一样的。与此同时，为了得到这一点，公司并不总是愿意付出相应的代价。而且，是的，这在 Facebook 真的很棒，对吧？比如，你会走过——比方说——世界上两个最优秀的网络工程师在白板前争论，你听着，你会学到——这在远程公司是不会发生的。你可能会跳上 Zoom 来解决它，但它仍然不一样，它是不同的。而且初级员工、职业生涯早期的员工在远程环境中会稍微艰难一些。当你有新人加入并且他们正在学习手艺时，你可以看出他们什么时候遇到了困难。他们通常坐在经理附近，看起来有点心不在焉，或者有点担忧，你知道的，他们看起来压力很大——这样更容易随时关注人们。是的，我看到在远程文化中，职业生涯早期的员工会真正陷入困境，相比于只是说“哦，我们可以去厨房喝杯咖啡，我有几个问题想问你”这种极其简单的方式，他们觉得预约一个 Zoom 通话的门槛太高了，形式主义太重了。所以，这同样充满了起起落落
and trade-offs and there's some really weird and bad takes on the internet about how you don't need offices or remote is terrible and you can't ever build a company remotely. Both takes a complete role. Yep. Yep. Yeah, I totally agree. So PlantScale is remote, totally distributed. And so are you hiring at the moment? We have a few roles open. Yeah.
和权衡取舍。互联网上有一些非常怪异和糟糕的观点，说什么你不需要办公室，或者远程办公糟糕透顶，你永远无法通过远程方式建立一家公司。这两种观点全都是错的。对，对。是的，我完全同意。所以 PlanetScale 是远程的、完全分布式办公的。那么你们现在还在招人吗？我们有几个开放的职位。是的。
We've got folks in customer success. We've got folks in sales. If you like computers and databases and want to work with some of the biggest companies in the world with their tech stacks and their most important part of the tech stack the database it's a really fun company to be you can get super nosy cool yeah that's awesome and what sort of uh so you know in general um you know not just hiring but in general like on the engineering side what sort of i'm trying to figure out how does someone engineering side, what sort of, I'm trying to figure out, how does someone get into, like, what sort of skillset are you looking for? Because, you know, my guess is you're not necessarily looking for people who are good at using
我们在客户成功部门有人员需求。我们在销售部门有人员需求。如果你喜欢计算机和数据库，并且想与世界上一些最大的公司合作，处理他们的技术栈以及技术栈中最核心的部分——数据库，那这将是一家非常有趣的公司。你可以变得非常充满好奇心。酷，太棒了。那么，大致说来……你知道，不仅是招人，一般来说，在工程端，你们在寻找什么样的……我在琢磨，一个人怎么才能——在工程端，你们在寻找什么样的技能组合？因为，你知道，我的猜测是，你们不一定在寻找那些擅长使用
a database. You're looking at people who have that, but are also really good at the insides of it. And so what is that most closest to like what's the skill set there you know there's really varied skill sets in in the plant skill engineering team you have the people that build our query parser right and they are working on really deep computer science that i just struggle to understand like you know this i'll go and look at what they're planning and it's all math notation. It's like, I don't understand any of this really. Like the complexity is there. It can be really tough.
数据库的人。你们在寻找那些不仅擅长使用、而且非常精通其内部原理的人。那么，最接近这种要求的技能组合是什么？PlanetScale 工程团队的技能组合其实非常多样化。有构建我们查询解析器（query parser）的人，他们正在研究我很难理解的极其深奥的计算机科学，你知道的，这——我会去看看他们在规划什么，全都是数学符号。我就想：我真的看不懂任何这些东西。那种复杂性就摆在那里。这确实很难。
So they're working on the core of the test, but they're not really called upon to build the UI because it's a completely different skill set, right? So the folks that build the UI, like our designers, they code, they hand it off to some of our services team that are fantastic javascript engineers our api and app is um a rails app with next.js up front for the
所以他们致力于测试的核心，但并没有真正要求他们去构建UI，因为这是完全不同的技能组合，对吧？所以构建UI的人，比如我们的设计师，他们写代码，然后交给我们的服务团队，这些团队都是非常出色的JavaScript工程师，我们的API和应用是一个……嗯，Rails应用，前端使用Next.js来构建
for the actual user interface but the things that talk to our cli then we have our middleware that schedules all this stuff to happen in the back end That's all written in Go. So Go backend engineering skills, understanding how to build services at scale that are reliable. It's a big varying skill set and people usually are specialists. We don't really have many people that are jumping around the stack doing it all. People have, we have hired such incredibly tenured and smart people that everyone gains respect for them mastering their craft and trust them to do the things that work extremely well for them.
实际的用户界面，但与我们的CLI进行交互的部分，我们有中间件来调度后台发生的所有这些事情。这些全都是用Go编写的。所以需要Go后端的工程技能，理解如何构建大规模且可靠的服务。这是一个很大的不同技能组合，大家通常都是专家。我们其实没有多少人在技术栈里跳来跳去什么都做。我们雇用了非常资深和聪明的人，以至于每个人都尊重他们精通自己的手艺，并信任他们能把对自己最擅长的事做得极其出色。
And we don't do anything by half measures. Like I said, our product designers have been building products for decades and have built famous and loved products. No database company has the ratio of designers because they just think they're wrong about what they're delivering to their users. They think they're there just to provide the backend. We just can't accept that. So we have to have great people doing all of it. Yeah, that makes a ton of sense. Yeah, I noticed that to use PlanetScale,
而且我们做事绝不半途而废。就像我说的，我们的产品设计师几十年来一直在构建产品，并打造过著名且深受喜爱的产品。没有任何一家数据库公司拥有这样比例的设计师，因为他们只是觉得产品交付给用户时那些设计师的想法是不对的。他们觉得设计师只是来提供后端的。我们简直无法接受这一点。所以我们必须让优秀的人来做所有这些事情。是的，这非常合乎情理。是的，我注意到要使用PlanetScale，
at least today in November, I had to use, I mean, to administer it, I used the MySQL workbench and you have to do kind of some finagling to get to the right branch and everything. But I think there's a huge opportunity there. Anytime I'm using a desktop app that takes more than three seconds to load,
至少在今年11月，我必须使用，我的意思是，为了管理它，我用了MySQL Workbench，你得做一些繁琐的操作才能找到正确的数据库分支等等。但我认为这里有一个巨大的机会。每当我使用的桌面应用加载时间超过三秒钟，
there's an opportunity there. So I'm really looking forward to seeing what comes up in the future. So before we head out, I wanted to talk about the book that you recommended. This is something that's a programming throwdown kind of mainstay. We always ask folks, what are books they recommended.
这里就有机会。所以我非常期待看到未来会出现什么。所以在我们结束之前，我想聊聊你推荐的那本书。这是Programming Throwdown类节目的支柱内容。我们总是问大家，他们推荐了什么书。
You recommended Amp It Up. So kind of talk us through Amp It Up and what's it about and how did it affect you and inspire you? It really resonated with me, this style of leadership and management that Slutman talks about. You know, we have one value at PlanetScale, everyday matters. We're going to add more, but I don't believe in just like, you know, you've seen company values rolled out where it's like 10 things that it's like no one could ever. Yeah, that's right. Yeah. Empathy. Cool. Yeah. Empathy is great. You should definitely have empathy,
你推荐了《Amp It Up》（火力全开）。所以请跟我们聊聊《Amp It Up》以及它讲的是什么，它对你有什么影响和启发？这真的引起了我的共鸣，Slutman谈论的那种领导和管理风格。你知道，我们在PlanetScale只有一个价值观：每天都很重要。我们打算增加更多，但我并不相信那种，你知道的，你见过公司推出的那种价值观，列出10件事情，结果根本没人能……对，没错。是的。同理心。酷。是的。同理心很棒。你绝对应该具备同理心，
but no company is going to disagree that you shouldn't have empathy. So why is it a product value? Why is it a company value? The company values should, people should look at it and go, oh, I completely firmly agree there and I would love to work at that place. Or, oh, I really disagree with doing it that way so I don't want to work there. They should be very divisive. If they're just a hand wavy thing that everyone's going to agree with,
但没有任何一家公司会反对你不该有同理心。那为什么它能成为一个产品价值观？为什么它能成为公司的价值观？公司的价值观应该让人看了之后觉得：哦，我完全坚决同意这一点，我很乐意在那样的公司工作。或者，哦，我真的不同意那样做，所以我不想在那里工作。它们应该是极具争议性的。如果它们只是一些人云亦云、每个人都会同意的东西，
useless value, not worth it. And so I read this book and I thought, this aligns with my values. i believe that you should work extremely hard and push for outsized results and so does everyone at plan scale they work so hard we don't burn ourselves out we we you know we take time in fact this this friday that just passed is one of our first fridays we all take one friday off a month together so we can all have like real. It's like impossible to take real vacation in the modern world with no notifications and you get phoned. Right.
那就是个无用的价值观，不值得一提。所以我读了这本书，我想，这与我的价值观不谋而合。我相信你应该极其努力工作，并争取超额的成果，PlanetScale的每个人也都是这样。他们工作非常努力，我们不会让自己精疲力竭，我们，你知道的，我们会抽时间，事实上，刚刚过去的这个星期五是我们第一次实行的“集体周五”，我们每个月一起放假一个星期五，这样我们就能真正拥有……在现代社会里，要想真正度过一个没有通知、不会接到电话的假期简直是不可能的。没错。
Right. So we have to give everyone a day off together to like really get them to chill. And that's great. It's funny though. People start creeping back onto work by Sunday. Cause I think they get lonely or bored, but they get antsy.
没错。所以我们必须给大家放同一天假，让他们真正放松下来。这太棒了。不过这挺搞笑的。人们到周日又开始悄悄回到工作岗位上了。因为我想他们会感到孤独或无聊，他们开始坐立不安。
I do certainly. But this is, you know, that's the thing is that it just felt right to me that this spirit of, of kind of aggressive motivation towards the goals that the company has. And, you know, we believe in that, which we want to run as small a company as possible with as good and the best people we can possibly find. And that takes running a really disciplined culture, giving, you can't
我确实会这样。但这就是重点，感觉对我来说很对，这种对公司目标的积极进取、充满干劲的精神。而且，你知道的，我们坚信这一点，我们希望以尽可能小的规模运营一家公司，并拥有我们能找到的最优秀的人才。这就需要实行一种高度纪律严明的文化，给予，你不能
hire amazing people and give them no autonomy. At the same time, if you have a highly autonomous culture with no accountability, you go, you go wildly off the rails. And so just a lot of the principles in that book really resonated with me. And I read it, you know, only recently, we've been running Planets Gal the way we run it for a while. And it just, and I had never really seen that style reflected in book form. And to read it you know i had a lot of respect and also it's from someone that has built an incredible company i mean i i can't really read business books of advice from folks that haven't done something that i find impressive and and i do very much find frank's work very impressive very cool just for context
雇用了不起的人却不给他们任何自主权。与此同时，如果你拥有一个高度自主却没有任何问责机制的文化，你就会彻底失控。因此，那本书中的许多原则确实深深打动了我。我读这本书的时间其实并不久，我们运作PlanetScale的方式已经有一段时间了。只是，我以前从未在书本形式中看到过这种风格的反映。读这本书时，你知道的，我非常尊敬作者，而且它出自一个打造了一家令人难以置信的公司的人之手——我的意思是，我其实不太读那些没有做过让我觉得印象深刻的事情的人所写的商业建议书籍，而我确实非常欣赏Frank的工作，非常酷。顺便补充一下背景，
so the person who wrote this book is the ceo is it former or current ceo of of uh of snowflake yeah it's awesome and has made many i think this is his third billion dollar company that he's created wow wow amazing cool yeah i'll have to check this out. This is right up my alley. I've been trying to read more on the product management side and trying to exercise that part of my brain. So this is personally, I think, super relevant. I'm excited to give this a read. I'm going to add it to to my Audible, which is a great segue to our shameless plug for Audible. If you're listening to this and you don't have an Audible account grab one um patrick and i've had them for a zillion years and i'm still uh you know active member reading a ton of books on there and you can also catch us on on patreon and support the show that way so either way we really appreciate folks folks supporting the show. And beyond supporting the show, even better is when folks write in.
所以写这本书的人是Snowflake的CEO，是前任还是现任CEO？是的，太棒了，而且创造了很多，我想这是他创建的第三家市值达十亿美元的公司。哇，太惊人了，酷。是的，我得去看看。这太对我的胃口了。我一直在试图阅读更多关于产品管理的书籍，并尝试锻炼我大脑的那部分功能。所以我个人认为这超级相关。我很兴奋能读一读这本书。我要把它加入我的Audible，这也是一个很好的过渡，顺便为Audible做一个厚颜无耻的广告。如果你在听这个节目却没有Audible账号，快去注册一个。帕特里克和我已经用了好多年了，我依然是一个活跃的会员，在上面读了大量的书。你也可以在Patreon上关注我们并以这种方式支持节目。无论哪种方式，我们都非常感谢支持节目的朋友们。除了支持节目，更好的是当大家写信给我们时。
And a lot of our interviews and a lot of other topics have been because folks have written in and suggested things to us. So we really appreciate that. So, yes, Sam, this was amazing having you on the show. You really were able to dive deep on databases, explain a bunch of different concepts to folks. I love some of the things that we covered around transactions and sharding and then moving on to PlanetScale
我们的许多采访和许多其他话题都是因为大家写信并向我们提出了建议。所以我们非常感激。所以，萨姆，你能来到我们的节目真是太棒了。你真的很深入地探讨了数据库，向大家解释了许多不同的概念。我非常喜欢我们讨论的一些关于事务和分片的内容，然后延伸到PlanetScale，
and how we're able to do kind of a more coding-like environment with branches and PRs and merging and all of that, but in the database world. I encourage all the folks out there to check out PlanetScale. It is totally free. I've had the same PlanetScale database for probably like 12 months now, and it hasn't given me any trouble, and they haven't asked me for a cent.
以及我们如何在数据库世界中实现一种更像编码的环境，带有分支、PR、合并以及所有这些功能。我鼓励所有的朋友去了解一下PlanetScale。它是完全免费的。我拥有同一个PlanetScale数据库大概已经有12个月了，它没有给我带来任何麻烦，而且他们也没有向我要过一分钱。
So maybe if my website gets popular enough, I'll hit some threshold. And if it does get that popular, I'd be more than happy to contribute. But up until now, it's been in the free tier, which is extremely generous. So folks out there, check it out. If you've never used a database before, there's an opportunity to use it for free without having to spin up a server or install a whole bunch of packages and deal with all of that. It's super accessible, definitely the easiest setup I've ever experienced. So check out PlanetScale. We'll put links in the show notes. And once again, Sam,
所以也许如果我的网站变得足够受欢迎，我会触及某个门槛。如果它真的那么受欢迎，我非常乐意进行付费支持。但到目前为止，它一直处于免费层，这非常慷慨。所以朋友们，去看看吧。如果你从未用过数据库，这是一个免费使用的机会，无需启动服务器或安装一堆软件包并处理所有这些麻烦。它超级平易近人，绝对是我体验过最简单的设置。所以去看看PlanetScale吧。我们会在节目说明中放置链接。再次感谢萨姆，
thanks so much for coming on to the show. Thank you so much for having me. I really, really enjoyed this time. Very, very enjoyable. Thank you. Sure. All right, everyone. I'll catch you all later. Music by Eric Farndaller. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
非常感谢你来到节目中。非常感谢邀请我。我真的非常享受这段时间。非常非常愉快。谢谢。好的，各位。我们回头见。音乐由Eric Farndaller创作。Programming Throwdown在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混音、改编，但你必须注明原作者帕特里克和我，并采用相同的许可方式。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。